If you want more from the show, join The Rest Is History Club. And with Christmas coming, you can also gift a whole year of access to the history lover in your life. Just head to the restishistory.com and click Gifts. This episode is sponsored by Hive. Britain revolutionised the future with the might of industrial power. But now you can transform your own energy future and take control with the power of Hive. Hive makes the most of the sun, with solar panels turning sunlight into greener electricity and enabling you to sell excess back to the grid. And Hive's thermostats make it possible
如果您想了解更多节目内容，请加入“历史就是如此”俱乐部（The Rest Is History Club）。随着圣诞节临近，您还可以为您生命中热爱历史的人送上一整年的会员资格。只需前往 restishistory.com 并点击“礼物”（Gifts）即可。本期节目由 Hive 赞助。英国曾以工业力量的强大推动了未来的变革。但现在，您可以利用 Hive 的力量来改变自己的能源未来并掌握主动权。Hive 充分利用太阳能，通过太阳能电池板将阳光转化为更环保的电力，并使您能够将多余的电力卖回电网。而 Hive 的恒温器让您能够
for you to heat your home without lifting anything more than a thumb and an impressed brow. Their heat pumps draw warmth from the air and they keep it exactly where you want it. No smoke, no waste. Hive's EV charger. your car charge quietly overnight. Recharging while you do too. Hive brings it all together. Heating, charging and solar managed from one simple app in a quiet revolution. In the long history of power, Hive helps you finally know yours. Head to hivehome.com to find out more. Subject to survey and suitability. Hive app compatible with selected technology. Paid for surplus requires
无需动一根手指，只需轻轻一点，就能轻松调节家中温度。他们的热泵从空气中汲取热量，并将其保持在您想要的精确温度。没有烟雾，没有浪费。Hive 的电动汽车充电器让您的汽车在夜间安静充电，在您休息的同时完成补能。Hive 将这一切融为一体。供暖、充电和太阳能管理，只需一个简单的应用程序，即可实现一场安静的革命。在漫长的能源史上，Hive 帮助您最终掌握自己的能源。前往 hivehome.com 了解更多信息。需视勘测和适用性而定。Hive 应用程序兼容特定技术。盈余电力需
SEG tariff Hello everybody now for the first time all of Goalhanger's chart-topping podcasts will be hitting the stage together for a weekend of thrilling shows and panels
SEG 关税。大家好，现在 Goalhanger 旗下所有排名第一的播客将首次齐聚舞台，为大家带来一个周末的精彩演出和座谈会。
we are so excited to announce the brilliantly titled The Rest is Fest it will be running from the 4th to the 6th of September and it will be at the South Bank Centre in London and we the rest is history
我们非常激动地宣布，这个名为“历史就是庆典”（The Rest is Fest）的活动将于 9 月 4 日至 6 日在伦敦南岸中心举行，而我们“历史就是如此”团队
will be performing on the Saturday that is the 5th of September 2026 at 4 o'clock at the Royal Festival Hall. Now members of the Restis History Club will be emailed a pre-sale link at 10 o'clock in the morning on the 4th of December
将于 2026 年 9 月 5 日星期六下午 4 点在皇家节日大厅进行表演。“历史就是如此”俱乐部的成员将在 12 月 4 日上午 10 点收到预售链接的电子邮件，
and the general sale will be at 10 o'clock in the morning on the 11th of December. So if you want early access for these tickets and if you want to see us live, just head to The Restis History You can sign up in a few clicks and you will be one of the lucky people who gets early access to this exciting and thrilling festival. the survival of Christian civilization.
而公开发售将于 12 月 11 日上午 10 点开始。所以，如果您想提前获得这些门票并想现场观看我们的演出，只需前往“历史就是如此”网站，点击几下即可注册，您将成为有幸提前获得这个激动人心、令人振奋的节日门票的人之一。基督教文明的存续。
Upon it depends our own British life and the long continuity of our institutions and our empire. The whole fury and might of the enemy must very soon be turned on us. Hitler knows that he will have to break out in this island or lose the war.
我们英国人的生活以及我们制度和帝国的长期延续都取决于此。敌人的全部愤怒和力量很快就会转向我们。希特勒知道，他必须在这个岛国取得突破，否则就会输掉这场战争。
If we can stand up to him, him, all Europe may be free, and the life of the world may move forward into broad, sunlit upland. But if we fail, then the whole world, including the United States, including all that we have known and cared for, will sink into the abyss of a new dark age, made more sinister and perhaps more protracted by the light of perverted shirene. Let us therefore brace ourselves to our duties, and so bear ourselves that if the British Empire and its Commonwealth last for a thousand years, men will still say, this was their finest hour.
如果我们能抵挡住他，整个欧洲或许就能获得自由，世界的生活也可能迈向广阔、阳光明媚的高地。但如果我们失败了，那么整个世界，包括美国，包括我们所知和所珍视的一切，都将沉入一个新的黑暗时代的深渊，这个时代因被扭曲的邪恶之光而变得更加阴险，或许也更加漫长。因此，让我们振作起来履行职责，表现出我们的风骨，这样即使大英帝国及其联邦能延续一千年，人们仍会说，这是他们最辉煌的时刻。
So, Dominic, any ideas who that was? Oh, God, I mean... It was, of course, Winston Churchill, and he was speaking in the House of Commons on Tuesday, the 18th of June, 1940, and he was speaking at a moment of supreme danger for Britain, quite possibly the darkest moment in Britain's long history. Definitely, I would say. You know, we've had the miracle of Dunkirk,
那么，多米尼克，有什么头绪那是谁吗？天哪，我的意思是……那当然是温斯顿·丘吉尔，他是在 1940 年 6 月 18 日星期二在下议院发表的演讲，当时正值英国处于极度危险的时刻，很可能是英国漫长历史上最黑暗的时刻。我肯定会这么说。你知道，我们经历了敦刻尔克奇迹，
the British troops and 100,000 other Allied troops have been got away from the trap that the Nazis had set for them. They're back in Britain, but, you know, the situation is still very, very bleak. The day before Churchill gave that speech, Marshal Petin had taken over as Prime Minister of France, had appealed to Hitler for an armistice. And I guess that what follows the defeat of the Luftwaffe in the Battle of Britain, the end of any prospect of the Germans carrying out Operation Sea Lion, the plan to invade and conquer Britain. This isn't just the most celebrated episode in modern British history, but more germanyly from the point of view of our current series, which is looking at the Second World War through the prism of the Nazis. It's a massive
英国军队和其他 10 万名盟军士兵从纳粹为他们设下的陷阱中逃脱了。他们回到了英国，但是，你知道，局势仍然非常、非常严峻。在丘吉尔发表那次演讲的前一天，贝当元帅接任了法国总理，并向希特勒请求停战。我想，接下来发生的是德国空军在不列颠战役中的失败，以及德国人执行“海狮计划”（即入侵并征服英国的计划）的任何希望的破灭。这不仅是现代英国历史上最著名的事件，而且从我们当前系列节目的角度来看，即通过纳粹的视角审视第二次世界大战，这是一个巨大的
turning point in the story of the Third Reich, isn't it? And we're not just indulging in British grandstanding in saying that. Never. Never on this podcast. When Churchill says that Hitler knows he will have to break us in this island or lose the war. I mean, he's not wrong there, is he? Not wrong at all. And even people who may be tempted to be skeptical will discover in this episode that it's precisely because of this that Hitler takes the catastrophic decision to launch his biggest gamble of all, which is the betrayal of Stalin, with whom he'd signed a pact, his decision to turn east and launch the invasion of the Soviet Union. And that all flows from his inability to break Britain in the summer of 1940, as we will discuss.
第三帝国故事的转折点，不是吗？我们说这话并非是在进行英国式的夸耀。绝不。在这个播客里绝不。当丘吉尔说希特勒知道他必须在这个岛国击垮我们，否则就会输掉战争时。我的意思是，他并没有说错，对吧？一点也没错。即使是那些可能倾向于怀疑的人也会在本集中发现，正是因为这一点，希特勒才做出了他最大的一场赌博——背叛了与他签署过互不侵犯条约的斯大林，决定转向东方并对苏联发动入侵。正如我们将要讨论的那样，这一切都源于他在 1940 年夏天无法击垮英国。
So, let's return to Germany in midsummer 1940. We ended last time with Hitler coming home to Berlin in triumph, having toured the conquered city of Paris. And among the ordinary people of Berlin, morale is now very high. They had complained all winter about their frozen wages and high prices, But now, American correspondents, for example, who are in Berlin, report seeing women wearing silk stockings plundered from Paris, local pubs and taverns with kind of bottles of contral and armagnac and expensive French drinks, the fruits of conquest, Tom. So, Dominic, can I just thought, I mean, how much plundering was there? Oh, loads.
那么，让我们回到 1940 年仲夏的德国。上次我们讲到希特勒在巡视了被征服的巴黎后，凯旋回到柏林。在柏林的普通民众中，士气现在非常高涨。他们整个冬天都在抱怨工资被冻结和物价高昂，但现在，例如身在柏林的美国记者报道说，看到妇女们穿着从巴黎掠夺来的丝袜，当地的酒吧和酒馆里摆满了君度酒、雅文邑白兰地和昂贵的法国酒，这些都是征服的果实，汤姆。那么，多米尼克，我只是在想，我的意思是，掠夺的程度有多大？哦，非常多。
Loads. So when the Germans entered cities, I mean, this is standard, by the way, in wartime. you know, when the Germans enter the cities which remember are deserted, what was it, Chartre population fell from 20,000 to 800 or something, you know, they go into these shops and they help themselves and they bring this stuff or send it back to Germany. And these might seem like trivial things, but these are little things that might make quite a big difference to the psychology of people who were previously anxious about fighting a war and now think they are winning. And I indeed now think they've effectively won it. I remember in my
非常多。所以当德国人进入城市时，我的意思是，顺便说一下，这在战时是常态。你知道，当德国人进入那些城市时，请记住，这些城市已经空无一人，比如沙特尔的人口从 2 万下降到了 800 左右，你知道，他们走进这些商店，随意拿走东西，然后把这些东西带回或寄回德国。这些看起来可能微不足道，但这些小事可能会对那些之前担心打仗、现在认为自己正在获胜的人的心理产生很大的影响。而且我确实认为他们现在已经有效地赢得了战争。我记得在我的
brother's book, The War in the West, which I've been quoting a lot in this series, he has an account of German girls and their misery at the fact that the only clothes available in the shops are all brown. And presumably, if soldiers are coming back from the chic boutiques of Paris, suddenly there's a little bit more glamour and colour. Yeah, of course. And if you're a soldier, I mean, being posted to Paris is, you know, the gig you want. And actually talking of soldiers, for the next year or so, if you are in the German army, you are unlikely to fire a shot in anger. Because this is the period for Germany, which feels like the phony war. You know, because effectively, as they see it, they've won the war in the West. You know,
兄弟的书《西线战争》中，我在这个系列中引用了很多次，他记录了德国女孩们对商店里只有棕色衣服可买的痛苦。据推测，如果士兵们从巴黎的时髦精品店回来，突然间就会多了一点魅力和色彩。是的，当然。如果你是一名士兵，我的意思是，被派往巴黎是你梦寐以求的工作。说到士兵，在接下来的一年左右，如果你在德国军队中，你不太可能在愤怒中开火。因为这对德国来说是一个感觉像是“假战”的时期。你知道，因为实际上，在他们看来，他们已经赢得了西线的战争。你知道，
there's very little more fighting to be done. The only issue is, of course, there is still the problem of Britain. Now, remember, as we've talked about many times in this series, Hitler has quite a complicated attitude to Britain. He sees the British's Anglo-Saxon racial cousins. That's bad news for the Celts, I suppose. He respects the British for building a vascular global empire. But at the same time, he knows there are people in Britain who are, you know, who will never give in to him, Churchill and co. And he hates and fears them and wants to bring them down. And there is a sense, isn't there, that he does view England, as he calls Britain, as his most dangerous enemy, more than France, really. Oh, definitely more than France,
几乎没有什么战斗需要进行了。唯一的问题当然是，英国的问题依然存在。现在，请记住，正如我们在本系列中多次讨论的那样，希特勒对英国的态度相当复杂。他视英国人为盎格鲁-撒克逊种族的表亲。我想这对凯尔特人来说是个坏消息。他尊重英国人建立了一个庞大的全球帝国。但与此同时，他知道英国有人，你知道，永远不会向他屈服，比如丘吉尔等人。他憎恨并恐惧他们，想要摧毁他们。有一种感觉，不是吗，他确实把英格兰（他称之为英国）视为他最危险的敌人，真的比法国更危险。哦，绝对比法国更危险，
definitely. Hitler despises the Soviet Union, for example. He knows he'll have to have a showdown with the Soviet Union, but he thinks that Slavs are subhuman and that Germany will easily be able to beat them. He respects and fears Britain and the United States. He sees them as the kind of Anglo-Saxon capitalist democracies with whom there will have to be a final reckoning for control of the planet. I mean, that's genuinely the way that he thinks. And he thinks he can knock the British out quickly by knocking the French out quickly. Because what he his thinks is, once France is out, once the British have been driven back into their island, ideally, the British people will realise that Churchill was a fool, you know, and a tool of
绝对是。例如，希特勒鄙视苏联。他知道他必须与苏联进行决战，但他认为斯拉夫人是劣等民族，德国可以轻易击败他们。他尊重并恐惧英国和美国。他视他们为那种必须进行最终清算以争夺地球控制权的盎格鲁-撒克逊资本主义民主国家。我的意思是，这确实是他思考的方式。他认为他可以通过迅速击败法国来迅速击垮英国。因为他的想法是，一旦法国出局，一旦英国人被赶回他们的岛屿，理想情况下，英国人民会意识到丘吉尔是个傻瓜，你知道，是
Jewish capitalism, and they will turn to a Lord Halifax or a David Lloyd George, or even maybe bring back Neville Chamberlain, and they will do a deal with Hitler. It's often said that David Lloyd George or someone, or Oswald Mosley, would be the equivalent of Marshall Petter in Britain. But presumably Britain would not have been defeated as calamitously as France. So the terms would presumably have been better. What kind of accommodation do you think Hitler would have been content with with Britain? Golly, this is a difficult one because this is into pure counterfactuals, but Hitler has already offered several times to guarantee Britain's empire. So he would probably have demanded the return of Germany's colonists from before the First World War.
犹太资本主义的工具，他们会转向哈利法克斯勋爵或大卫·劳合·乔治，甚至可能请回内维尔·张伯伦，他们会与希特勒达成协议。人们常说大卫·劳合·乔治或某人，或者奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利，会是英国的贝当元帅。但据推测，英国不会像法国那样遭受灾难性的失败。所以条件大概会更好。你认为希特勒会满足于与英国达成什么样的妥协？天哪，这是一个难题，因为这纯粹是反事实的推测，但希特勒已经多次提出要保证大英帝国的安全。所以他可能会要求归还德国在一战前的殖民地，
so colonies in, for example, what's now Namibia, maybe Cameroon, Tanganyika, maybe the transfer of some French colonies, who knows, or the old British colony. But by and large, he wanted, as we saw last time, to preserve the British Empire because he doesn't want other predators to get those colonies, meaning Japan, the Soviet Union, the United States. Within Britain itself, an allied regime that probably joins him in a crusade against Bolshevism, eventually in the East, I suppose. It depends, of course, whether they just made a deal without being conquered.
比如在现在的纳米比亚、也许是喀麦隆、坦噶尼喀的殖民地，也许是转让一些法国殖民地，谁知道呢，或者是旧的英国殖民地。但总的来说，正如我们上次所见，他想保留大英帝国，因为他不希望其他掠食者得到那些殖民地，这意味着日本、苏联、美国。在英国国内，一个盟友政权可能会加入他反对布尔什维主义的十字军东征，最终在东方，我想。当然，这取决于他们是否在没有被征服的情况下达成了协议。
If they make a deal without being conquered, then he's not going to massively interfere, probably, in Britain's internal arrangements, I would imagine. I mean, basically, Britain would become a satellite state, a kind of client state. But there would be, what does he want? Probably some form of national government, you know, right-leaning. There's a difference in a Moseley and Lloyd George.
如果他们在没有被征服的情况下达成协议，那么他可能不会大规模干预英国的内部安排，我想。我的意思是，基本上，英国会成为一个卫星国，一种附庸国。但会有什么呢？他想要什么？可能是一种全国性的政府，你知道，右倾的。莫斯利和劳合·乔治之间是有区别的。
Mosley is more of the Quisling model, isn't he? Lloyd-George is more of the Paita, the World War I hero who comes back. back. Of course it doesn't happen because Hitler has completely misunderstood the mood in Britain after Dunkirk. I mean, Ian Kershaw says in his biography, what Hitler never really understands is how much British public opinion has shifted after 1938 after Munich. After Munich, there's probably no deal that Britain is going to make with Hitler. Even though we, you know, if Lord Halifax had been prime minister, it might have come close, but there were a lot of people that would have
莫斯利更像是吉斯林（Quisling）模式，不是吗？劳合·乔治更像是贝当，那个回归的一战英雄。当然，这并没有发生，因为希特勒完全误解了敦刻尔克之后英国的情绪。我的意思是，伊恩·克肖在他的传记中说，希特勒从未真正理解 1938 年慕尼黑协议之后英国公众舆论发生了多大的转变。慕尼黑之后，英国可能不会与希特勒达成任何协议。即使我们，你知道，如果哈利法克斯勋爵是首相，可能会很接近，但有很多人会
opposed it, I would say. And also, as we mentioned in our previous episode, Dunker, also has a huge role in perhaps giving a bit of optimism to Britain, where really there are a few grounds for optimism. Yeah, totally. Definitely agree. So actually, you know what you brilliantly Frenchiloquized Winston Churchill, you know, the Battle of Britain is about to begin or whatever it is. Hitler is only half expecting at this point to launch an attack on Britain. He's hoping that it won't be necessary. He said last time to Goebbels after visiting Paris, he said, you know, I'm going to make a last offer to the British. I'm going to make them a general offer and hopefully they will finally see sense. And is that in part because he has,
反对它，我会说。而且，正如我们在上一集中提到的，敦刻尔克在给英国带来一点乐观情绪方面也起到了巨大的作用，尽管实际上几乎没有什么乐观的理由。是的，完全同意。绝对同意。所以实际上，你知道你精彩地模仿了温斯顿·丘吉尔，你知道，不列颠战役即将开始之类的。希特勒此时只是半信半疑地准备对英国发动攻击。他希望这不是必要的。他上次在访问巴黎后对戈培尔说，他说，你知道，我要给英国人最后一个提议。我要给他们一个总的提议，希望他们最终能明白道理。这部分是因为他有，
you know, his perspective is very continentalist. He assumes that if the British have left the continent, then essentially they've lost the war. And he doesn't properly have a handle on the kind of global dimension that Britain can bring to the conflict. I don't think it's that, actually. I think in a weird way, what Hitler does is he overestimates the importance of the British Empire to Britain. That will sound weird to a lot of listeners. That is interesting. No, that is interesting. See, he looks at it and he thinks, if you carry on fighting, if you exhaust your resources in trying to fight me, he'll probably lose your empire. Spoiler alert, that's exactly what happens.
你知道，他的视角非常大陆主义。他假设如果英国人离开了欧洲大陆，那么本质上他们就输掉了战争。他并没有真正掌握英国能给冲突带来的全球维度。我不认为是因为那个，实际上。我认为以一种奇怪的方式，希特勒高估了大英帝国对英国的重要性。这对很多听众来说听起来很奇怪。这很有趣。不，这确实很有趣。你看，他看着它，他认为，如果你继续战斗，如果你在试图与我战斗中耗尽你的资源，你可能会失去你的帝国。剧透预警，这正是发生的事情。
He thinks, well, obviously the British would only care about their empire. Nothing would matter more to them than being strong and influential in the world. You know, Churchill, who loves the empire more than anybody, presides over a war that basically destroys Britain's ability to keep hold of its empire. I mean, that's the kind of irony of the whole thing. Anyway, Hitler's planning to give this big speech, where he's going to make this offer. And he plans initially to give it on the 8th of July, which is two days after he's got home from France. But he postpones it, and the reason he postpones it is because of a really interesting development in North Africa. The French had the fourth biggest fleet in the world, and Churchill was desperate to stop it falling into German hands, and he doesn't trust Marshall Payton's assurances that they won't let that happen.
他想，好吧，显然英国人只会关心他们的帝国。没有什么比在世界上强大和有影响力更重要的了。你知道，比任何人都热爱帝国的丘吉尔，主持了一场基本上摧毁了英国保持其帝国能力能力的战争。我的意思是，这就是整个事情的讽刺之处。无论如何，希特勒计划发表这个大演讲，他将在演讲中提出这个提议。他最初计划在 7 月 8 日发表，也就是他从法国回家后的两天。但他推迟了，他推迟的原因是北非发生了一个非常有趣的进展。法国拥有世界上第四大海军舰队，丘吉尔拼命想阻止它落入德国手中，他不相信贝当元帅保证他们不会让这种情况发生。
I mean, he does kind of, he gives the French fleet in Mersel-Kabir an ultimatum, doesn't he? And British officers kind of plead with the French to do it. And it's when they say no that the decision is taken. And that decision is a reflection of the fact that the British are prepared to be incredibly brutal themselves in their fight for survival. So just to explain to the listeners, this is in Algeria, basically a Meizel-Kibir, where the French Mediterranean fleet is based. and as you say to them, the British basically give them an ultimatum, their own allies. You know, join us, hand yourselves over to us, or we'll destroy you. The French don't do it, and so the British destroy them and kill more than 1,000 French sailors.
我的意思是，他确实有点，他给凯比尔港的法国舰队下了最后通牒，不是吗？英国军官恳求法国人这样做。当他们拒绝时，决定就做出了。这个决定反映了一个事实，即英国人在为生存而战时准备好变得极其残忍。所以向听众解释一下，这基本上是在阿尔及利亚的凯比尔港，法国地中海舰队的基地。正如你对他们所说，英国人基本上给了他们一个最后通牒，他们自己的盟友。你知道，加入我们，向我们投降，否则我们就摧毁你们。法国人没有这样做，所以英国人摧毁了他们，杀死了 1000 多名法国水手。
The Vichy government, you know, Peyton, who was already quite down on the British, says, this is like the worst betrayal in human history. He breaks off diplomatic relations with Britain. It sends a really clear signal to the world. Yeah, it does. Britain's not messing around. You know, Churchill's not going to be doing any deals. we're really going to do whatever it takes.
维希政府，你知道，本来就对英国人很反感的贝当说，这就像人类历史上最严重的背叛。他断绝了与英国的外交关系。这向世界发出了一个非常明确的信号。是的，确实。英国人不是在开玩笑。你知道，丘吉尔不会做任何交易。我们真的会不惜一切代价。
And the Germans had hoped they would get the French fleets and that would help them win control of the channel if they had to. I mean, it now means they have to win control of the skies if they're going to get across the channel. So that's, you know, it's preparing the ground for the Battle of Britain. But of course, it gives Hitler pause for thought. So now he postpones the speech. Interestingly, he doesn't really know what to do.
德国人曾希望他们能得到法国舰队，如果必须的话，这将有助于他们赢得海峡的控制权。我的意思是，现在这意味着如果他们要穿过海峡，他们必须赢得天空的控制权。所以，你知道，这正在为不列颠战役做准备。但当然，这让希特勒犹豫不决。所以现在他推迟了演讲。有趣的是，他真的不知道该怎么办。
In this episode, we will see Hitler at his most indecisive and confused because the British are just not behaving as he thinks they ought to. So he talks to Goebbels again. Goebbels records in his diary on the 9th of July. Despite all this, the Fuhrer still has a very positive attitude towards England. He's still not ready for the final blow. He wants to think over his speech again in peace. So Hitler postpones the speech.
在这一集中，我们将看到希特勒最优柔寡断和困惑的一面，因为英国人的表现并不像他认为的那样。所以他再次与戈培尔交谈。戈培尔在 7 月 9 日的日记中记录道：尽管如此，元首对英国仍然持非常积极的态度。他还没有准备好进行最后一击。他想平静地再次考虑他的演讲。所以希特勒推迟了演讲。
He goes off to his mountain lair, the Ober Salzberg, in southern Germany, and he summons his military chiefs. So first of all, Grand Admiral Eric Rébel. leader, who is the head of the Kriegsmarine, the Navy High Command. Now, Raider is a, you know, your classic kind of career naval officer, conservative Prussian family, right wing. He has been working since 1939 on invasion plans for Britain. And he knows that this is a massive challenge because his Navy has taken a hammering in
他去了他在德国南部的山中巢穴——上萨尔茨堡，并召集了他的军事首领。首先是海军元帅埃里希·雷德尔，他是德国海军最高指挥部（Kriegsmarine）的负责人。现在，雷德尔是一个，你知道，你典型的职业海军军官，保守的普鲁士家庭，右翼。他从 1939 年就开始制定入侵英国的计划。他知道这是一个巨大的挑战，因为他的海军在
the Norway campaign. Of course, the Bluca got blown up, didn't it? The Bluco got blown up by the Norwegians very heroically. Well done the Norwegians. So Raider has three cruisers and four destroyers that he can call on in the channel and the British Channel fleet is five battleships, 11 cruisers and 30 destroyers. So the odds are very, very clearly in Britain's favour. One thing to consider is that we don't like having the advantage of numbers.
挪威战役中遭受了重创。当然，“布吕歇尔”号被炸沉了，不是吗？“布吕歇尔”号被挪威人非常英勇地炸沉了。挪威人干得好。所以雷德尔有三艘巡洋舰和四艘驱逐舰可以在海峡调用，而英国海峡舰队有五艘战列舰、11 艘巡洋舰和 30 艘驱逐舰。所以胜算非常、非常明显地在英国一边。有一点要考虑的是，我们不喜欢拥有数量优势。
So perhaps we'd be unsettled by that. We're unsettled by the odds being in our favour. We always perform pluckily and generally win when the odds are against us. But I think we often do even better when the odds are in our favour. So I think it's just win-win, really. That's just the nature of it. And I don't want any complaints from people who don't pay their taxes on the other side of the Atlantic. So then Hitler receives the Vermak Chief of Staff General France Haldor.
所以也许我们会因此感到不安。我们对胜算在我们这边感到不安。我们总是表现得勇敢，并且通常在胜算不利于我们时获胜。但我认为我们在胜算在我们这边时往往表现得更好。所以我认为这真的是双赢。这就是它的本质。我不想听到任何在大西洋彼岸不纳税的人的抱怨。所以希特勒接见了德国国防军参谋长弗朗茨·哈尔德将军。
Halder was the bloat, the kind of clipped guy with glasses. He was trying to get rid of Hitler in episode one of this little bit of the series. A given up, hadn't he? And had given up, exactly. Again, Halder is very, you know, he can see that Hitler doesn't know what to do. He writes afterwards, the fear is greatly puzzled by England's persisting unwillingness to make peace. He sees the answer as we do, now this is interesting, in England's hope in Russia, and therefore counts on having to compel her by main force to agree to peace.
哈尔德是一个臃肿的、戴着眼镜的家伙。他在本系列的第一集中试图摆脱希特勒。放弃了，不是吗？确实放弃了，没错。同样，哈尔德非常，你知道，他能看出希特勒不知道该怎么办。他后来写道：元首对英国坚持不愿讲和感到非常困惑。他像我们一样看到了答案，现在这很有趣，在于英国对俄罗斯的希望，因此指望必须以武力迫使她同意和平。
Actually, that's much against his grain. So it's interesting that HALDA thinks that the British are hoping that Russia will change sides. Then he goes on. The reason that Hitler doesn't want to do it, really, is that a military defeat of England would bring about the disintegration of the British Empire. This would not be of any benefit to Germany. German blood would be shed to accomplish something that would benefit only Japan the United States and others. So again, the Germans don't want to see the British Empire
实际上，这违背了他的本意。所以哈尔德认为英国人希望俄罗斯会倒戈，这很有趣。然后他继续说。希特勒不想这样做的真正原因是，对英国的军事失败将导致大英帝国的瓦解。这对德国没有任何好处。德国人的鲜血将白流，只会让日本、美国和其他国家受益。所以同样，德国人不想看到大英帝国
fall apart. Preserving that is really important, their long-term plan for the kind of conquest of the planet. Hitler is speaking to an admiral and to a general. And again, I was talking about this with my brother. He said, the mad thing about this is that there's no kind of combined services general staff. So the admiral and the general are not talking to each other. So all the for kind of amphibious campaign. They have no concept of how to launch an amphibious campaign because the Navy and the Army
分崩离析。保留它对他们那种征服地球的长期计划非常重要。希特勒正在与一位海军上将和一位将军交谈。同样，我当时和我兄弟谈论这个。他说，这件事疯狂的地方在于没有联合参谋部。所以海军上将和将军之间没有沟通。所以对于那种两栖作战。他们根本没有概念如何发动两栖作战，因为海军和陆军
aren't talking to each other. And also the man running the Luftwaffe is an extremely unreliable man who's more interested in like hunting trophies and looted art and eating, and that's Herman Goering. And I think it is really difficult when you're looking at German prospects in 1940.
没有沟通。而且管理德国空军的人是一个极其不可靠的人，他更感兴趣的是狩猎战利品、掠夺艺术品和吃东西，那就是赫尔曼·戈林。我认为当你审视 1940 年德国的前景时，这真的很困难。
They have done so well. They have kind of oblitted everybody in their face. And yet there is still this kind of makeshift degree of incompetence about the organisation of the armed forces that is kind of lurking there and will slowly emerge over the course of the next years. Yeah, and over the course of this episode, actually. Now, there is another option. There is another possibility about how to bring Britain to heal.
他们做得太好了。他们基本上消灭了面前的所有人。然而，武装部队的组织中仍然存在这种临时拼凑的无能，它潜伏在那里，并将在未来几年慢慢显现出来。是的，实际上在这一集中也是如此。现在，还有另一个选择。关于如何让英国屈服，还有另一种可能性。
And this is that you could get a fifth columnist to do your job for you. Now, while he's at his lair, Hitler says to his cronist, God, I wish I'd worked harder to win over Edward VIII when he was king. and he's also muttering about Oswald Mosley. Mosley's under arrest at this point, the leader of the British Union of fascists. And actually somebody who really likes the idea of Edward VIII, who is now, of course, has amnicated
那就是你可以找一个第五纵队来为你做这份工作。现在，当他在他的巢穴时，希特勒对他的亲信说，天哪，我真希望我当初更努力地争取爱德华八世，当他还是国王的时候。他还在嘟囔着奥斯瓦尔德·莫斯利。莫斯利此时被捕了，他是英国法西斯联盟的领导人。实际上，有一个人真的很喜欢爱德华八世的想法，他现在当然已经退位了，
because of his relationship with Wallace Simpson and he's become the Duke of Windsor. Somebody who really likes the idea of using him is the top German sparkling wine salesman, Joachim von Ribbentrop, who'd been a bastard to Britain. and now foreign minister, one of the worst people who's ever lived. Ribbentrop, because he hated Britain.
因为他与华莱士·辛普森的关系，他成为了温莎公爵。有一个人真的很喜欢利用他的想法，那就是德国顶级起泡酒推销员，曾对英国表现得像个混蛋的约阿希姆·冯·里宾特洛甫，现在是外交部长，有史以来最糟糕的人之一。里宾特洛甫，因为他憎恨英国。
I mean, he really does hate Britain, and he thinks, let's bring back the worst king in British history. This is a brilliant idea. Now, this is a mad story. Edward and Wallace are in Portugal. They are going around telling everybody Britain has lost and should make peace with the Nazis. And Ribbentrop goes to this bloke and gets an SS officer called Valleter Schellenberg and says, I want you to do a job for me. Basically, I want you to lure them across the border into Franco's Spain.
我的意思是，他真的非常憎恨英国，他想，让我们请回英国历史上最糟糕的国王。这是一个绝妙的主意。现在，这是一个疯狂的故事。爱德华和华莱士在葡萄牙。他们到处告诉每个人英国已经输了，应该与纳粹讲和。里宾特洛甫去找了这个家伙，找了一个叫瓦尔特·谢伦伯格的党卫军军官，说，我想要你为我做一份工作。基本上，我想要你把他们引诱过边境进入佛朗哥的西班牙。
And then this is how it will work. Edward and Wallace will be invited to go hunting on the Portuguese border with Spain. Their guides will trick them and lure them across the border into Spain. And there they'll be kidnapped by German agents. And then they will take Edward to a safe house and offer him 50 million francs to accept the British crown as a Nazi puppet. And he'd probably have taken it, wouldn't he? Yeah, and he's quite a bad man, so he might have taken it. So here's the thing.
然后这就是它的运作方式。爱德华和华莱士将被邀请去葡萄牙与西班牙边境狩猎。他们的向导会欺骗他们，把他们引诱过边境进入西班牙。在那里，他们将被德国特工绑架。然后他们会把爱德华带到一个安全屋，并提供 5000 万法郎让他接受英国王位，成为纳粹的傀儡。他可能会接受的，不是吗？是的，他是个坏人，所以他可能会接受。所以事情是这样的。
Ribbentrop knows that the British wouldn't like this. He actually thinks that it might make an invasion more likely, but he loves that idea because he really wants to invade Britain. He hates Britain. He wants to see as many British people die as possible. And he wants to force all those gentlemen's clubs to give him honorary membership. And all those tailors who'd laugh at his shoes or whatever, his ill-fitting suits.
里宾特洛甫知道英国人不会喜欢这样。他实际上认为这可能会使入侵更有可能，但他喜欢这个主意，因为他真的想入侵英国。他憎恨英国。他想看到尽可能多的英国人死去。他想强迫所有那些绅士俱乐部给他荣誉会员资格。还有所有那些嘲笑他的鞋子或什么的裁缝，他那不合身的西装。
He'll get his revenge. But there's bad news for Ribbon Trot. First of all, Edward doesn't want to go hunting on the Portuguese border. He says no. And then a disaster. Churchill, to get rid of them, offers Edward, the job of governor of the Bahamas. So this SS bloke, Schallenberg, he sends them death threats hidden in bouquets of flowers, saying, you go to the Bahamas, you'll die.
他会报仇的。但里宾特洛甫有个坏消息。首先，爱德华不想去葡萄牙边境狩猎。他说不。然后是一场灾难。丘吉尔为了摆脱他们，给了爱德华巴哈马总督的工作。所以这个党卫军家伙，谢伦伯格，他给他们寄了藏在花束里的死亡威胁，说，你去巴哈马，你就会死。
The Bahamas. And also spreads rumors that the Bahamas are a terrible place and they shouldn't go. So he basically bribes their chauffeur. to tell them how awful the Bahamas are. Anyway, this is absolutely useless. They do go to the Bahamas, and my favorite detail of this is that Schellenberg's sort of parting shot is outrageous to have their luggage severely delayed.
巴哈马。而且还散布谣言说巴哈马是个糟糕的地方，他们不应该去。所以他基本上贿赂了他们的司机，告诉他们巴哈马有多糟糕。无论如何，这完全没用。他们确实去了巴哈马，我最喜欢的一个细节是谢伦伯格那种临别赠言是极其无耻的，让他们的行李严重延误。
Zadville shows them. You can imagine him laughing in a sinister way. The funny thing about this, the twist is everybody else absolutely hated Ribbentrop in the Nazi regime. So when Schellenberg got back to Berlin, Reinhardt Heidrich congratulated him on having made such a mess of the operation. said, brilliant, good job. You did exactly what we wanted because we didn't want Ribbentrop to get the win. While all this has been happening, Hitler has inched closer
扎德维尔向他们展示了。你可以想象他以一种阴险的方式大笑。这件事有趣的地方在于，纳粹政权里的其他所有人都绝对憎恨里宾特洛甫。所以当谢伦伯格回到柏林时，莱因哈德·海德里希祝贺他把行动搞得一团糟。说，太棒了，干得好。你做了我们想要的事情，因为我们不想让里宾特洛甫赢得胜利。当这一切发生时，希特勒已经慢慢接近
to a decision. On the 16th of July, he signed an order to prepare a landing operation against England, codenamed Sailover, sea lion. But even that order is hedged about with caveats if it should be necessary, because he's still hoping that the British will come to their senses. And then on the evening of Friday the 19th, he finally makes this great peace offer. It's a huge spectacle. The Reichstag is meeting at the Kroll Opera House. All his generals have been kind of promoted or decorated, and they're sitting in the front row a sort of sea of bling and medals. Guring has been promoted to Reichs Marshall, so he's wearing an even more extravagant uniform than ever. You know, great beam over his massive face. Hitler gives
一个决定。7 月 16 日，他签署了一项准备对英登陆作战的命令，代号为“海狮”（Seelöwe）。但即使是那个命令也带有警告，如果必要的话，因为他仍然希望英国人能清醒过来。然后在 7 月 19 日星期五晚上，他终于提出了这个伟大的和平提议。这是一个巨大的奇观。帝国议会在克罗尔歌剧院开会。他所有的将军都被晋升或授予勋章，他们坐在前排，像一片闪闪发光的勋章海洋。戈林被晋升为帝国元帅，所以他穿着比以往任何时候都更奢华的制服。你知道，他那张巨大的脸上带着灿烂的笑容。希特勒发表了
this speech, and apparently he's on top form, William Shira, the American correspondent, said it was one of the best speeches Hitler gave. He got to the end and he said, I want to make a last appeal to reason and common sense. I'm not the vanquished begging favors. I'm the victor speaking in the name of reason. Basically, I don't like war. Hitler says I'm in the irony. I don't like war. I don't like to think of all the sacrifices and suffering. I hope Churchill, a warmonger. I hope he'll listen to reason if he doesn't. It will end with the complete annihilation of Britain. But actually, I mean, he's had all this time to think of this offer.
这个演讲，显然他处于最佳状态，美国记者威廉·夏伊勒说这是希特勒发表的最好的演讲之一。他讲到最后说，我想向理性和常识发出最后的呼吁。我不是乞求恩惠的战败者。我是以理性的名义说话的胜利者。基本上，我不喜欢战争。希特勒说，讽刺的是，我不喜欢战争。我不喜欢想到所有的牺牲和痛苦。我希望丘吉尔，一个战争贩子。我希望他能听从理性，如果他不听。这将以英国的彻底毁灭而告终。但实际上，我的意思是，他有这么多时间来考虑这个提议。
And it is so vague and insubstantial. You know, that's all it is. There's no specifics at all. And Churchill rejects it that very evening. It's clear that the British are never going to accept it. And the mad thing is that so many people in Germany are genuinely surprised. So Shira, the American correspondent, he listens to the news. with a load of German senior officers and senior Nazis.
而且它是如此模糊和空洞。你知道，仅此而已。根本没有任何具体内容。丘吉尔在当天晚上就拒绝了它。很明显，英国人永远不会接受它。疯狂的是，德国有这么多人真的感到惊讶。所以美国记者夏伊勒，他听了新闻。和一大群德国高级军官和高级纳粹分子在一起。
And they are genuinely surprised. Can you make it out? Can you understand these British fools to turn down peace now? Shara said, they have nothing against Britain. They think they can lick Britain if it comes to a showdown, but they prefer peace. They can't get their heads around Britain's stubbornness, as they see it. And Richard Evans, in his book on the third right,
他们真的感到惊讶。你能理解吗？你能理解这些英国傻瓜现在拒绝和平吗？夏伊勒说，他们对英国没有任何意见。他们认为如果真的摊牌，他们可以击败英国，但他们更喜欢和平。他们无法理解英国人的顽固，正如他们所看到的那样。理查德·埃文斯在他的《第三帝国》一书中，
says a lot of this is down to Nazi propaganda. They basically believe their own propaganda. And the people, ordinary people, genuinely think the British are the warmongers. The British have forced war upon us. And, you know, we're making them these generous offers. And the British are just swatting them aside because they're the tools of Jewish finance capitalism. Isn't that what kind of chat show hosts in America? Some of them think that.
说这很大程度上归咎于纳粹宣传。他们基本上相信自己的宣传。而普通民众，普通人，真的认为英国人是战争贩子。英国人强加战争于我们。而且，你知道，我们正在向他们提出这些慷慨的提议。而英国人只是把它们扫到一边，因为他们是犹太金融资本主义的工具。这不就是美国脱口秀主持人所说的吗？他们中的一些人是这么想的。
American podcasters. Right-wing American podcasters now make this point. So Churchill has said no. even now Hitler is dithering and again Hitler the gambler the man who always launches the decisive stroke this is arguably the first time since he became chastewed Germany that he's faced with a really really big decision and he genuinely does not know what to do because as deluded as he is he knows that Britain as an island as an empire as an industrial superpower is going to be very very hard to beat to conquer. Anyway, on the 21st of July, an absolutely crucial day in the history of the
美国播客。现在的右翼美国播客也提出了这一点。所以丘吉尔说了不。即使现在希特勒也在犹豫不决，再次，希特勒这个赌徒，那个总是发动决定性一击的人，这可以说是他成为德国元首以来，第一次面临一个非常、非常大的决定，他真的不知道该怎么办，因为尽管他被误导了，但他知道英国作为一个岛国，作为一个帝国，作为一个工业超级大国，将是非常、非常难以击败、难以征服的。无论如何，在 7 月 21 日，我认为这是第三帝国历史上绝对关键的一天。
Third Reich, I would say. He meets his commanders and he says, okay, finalize your invasion plans. We'll strike between mid-August and mid-September. But then, and this is the important bit, at this meeting for the very first time, he mentions an alternative way of ending the war, possibly an easier way. And this is it. He says, why are the British holdings? Why are the British out because clearly they hope that one day they will get help from another world power, probably the Soviet Union. Now, Hitler and Stalin, of course, have been in a non-aggression pact since 1939, and Stalin since then has seized at Eastern Poland and a bit of Finland.
他会见了他的指挥官，他说，好吧，敲定你们的入侵计划。我们将在 8 月中旬到 9 月中旬之间发动攻击。但是，这是重要的一点，在这次会议上，他第一次提到了结束战争的另一种方式，可能是一种更容易的方式。就是这个。他说，为什么英国还在坚持？为什么英国人还不退出，因为显然他们希望有一天他们能得到另一个世界大国的帮助，可能是苏联。现在，希特勒和斯大林当然自 1939 年以来一直处于互不侵犯条约中，而斯大林自那时以来已经夺取了波兰东部和芬兰的一部分。
Stalin has also, while Hitler has been in Paris, Stalin has annexed the three Baltic states of Latvia, Lithuania and Estonia, and he took a bit of Romania, Bessarabia and northern Bukovina. Stalin has been kind of biting off bits of Europe. But Stalin's never going to attack Hitler. He knows the Red Army is too weak. And Stalin does not a gambler, so he's not going to take that risk. But now for the first time, 21st of July, Hitler says to his generals,
斯大林也，当希特勒在巴黎时，斯大林吞并了拉脱维亚、立陶宛和爱沙尼亚这三个波罗的海国家，并夺取了罗马尼亚的一部分，比萨拉比亚和北布科维纳。斯大林一直在蚕食欧洲。但斯大林永远不会攻击希特勒。他知道红军太弱了。而且斯大林不是一个赌徒，所以他不会冒那个险。但现在是第一次，7 月 21 日，希特勒对他的将军们说，
maybe we should break the pact with Stalin. Maybe we should attack him. What was surprised listeners, I think, is that you might think, well, this is because Hitler has always wanted to do this. He's got a racial hatred for the Slavs. he hates Bolshevism, he wants to carve out an empire in the east, Laban's Ram, all this. But that's not the reason that he wants to do it now. You know, Ian Kershaw in his biography of Hitler is absolutely explicit about this.
也许我们应该撕毁与斯大林的条约。也许我们应该攻击他。我想听众会感到惊讶的是，你可能会认为，好吧，这是因为希特勒一直想这样做。他对斯拉夫人有种族仇恨，他憎恨布尔什维主义，他想在东方开辟一个帝国，生存空间（Lebensraum），所有这些。但这不是他现在想这样做原因。你知道，伊恩·克肖在他的希特勒传记中对此非常明确。
This is about the strategic need to get Britain out of the war. Hitler says to his generals, if Russia is smashed, that is the end of any hopes that England might have of a change in this situation. In other words, it will send a message to England. You are totally on your own. And there's no help coming. What about America? Isn't Hitler worried about the possibility that America might come to Britain's rescue?
这是关于让英国退出战争的战略需要。希特勒对他的将军们说，如果俄罗斯被粉碎，那就是英国可能改变这种局势的任何希望的终结。换句话说，它将向英国发出一个信息。你们完全孤立无援了。而且没有援助会到来。那美国呢？希特勒不担心美国可能来拯救英国的可能性吗？
And indeed is kind of girding her loins to do exactly that in the summer of 1940. So here's the thing. I think Hitler knows that the Americans are a factor, but it's an election year. Roosevelt is facing re-election in an isolationist country. And Roosevelt is promising Americans, even while this is going on, you know, we're not going to get involved in another European war. So Hitler knows that he probably has a window of maybe a year, two years, before the Americans might get involved.
事实上，在 1940 年夏天，美国确实在为做到这一点而蓄势待发。所以事情是这样的。我认为希特勒知道美国是一个因素，但这是一个选举年。罗斯福在一个孤立主义国家面临连任。罗斯福向美国人承诺，即使在这一切发生时，你知道，我们不会卷入另一场欧洲战争。所以希特勒知道他可能有一年、两年的窗口期，在美军可能介入之前。
And what is more, if he can knock Britain out, either through a deal with Britain or by invading Britain, or by persuading the British to give up because he's crushed the Soviet Union, then the Americans are no longer even a factor. So if we do all this, this is just thinking, if we do all this, we don't even need to worry about America, because without the British, the Americans will never get involved in Europe. I mean, he knows that at some point there'll have to be a showdown with the Americans, you know, in 1949 or something. But he's not anticipating it straight away, I would say. And of course, he thinks, you know, attacking America would be difficult, how on earth you're
而且更重要的是，如果他能击垮英国，无论是通过与英国达成协议，还是通过入侵英国，或者通过说服英国放弃，因为他已经粉碎了苏联，那么美国甚至不再是一个因素。所以如果我们做这一切，这只是在想，如果我们做这一切，我们甚至不需要担心美国，因为没有英国，美国永远不会卷入欧洲。我的意思是，他知道在某个时候必须与美国摊牌，你知道，在 1949 年左右。但他并没有预料到会立即发生，我会说。当然，他认为，你知道，攻击美国会很困难，你到底怎么能
going to get over there. But attacking the Soviet Union, he says to his generals at this meeting, I think we'll need maybe 80, 100 divisions, let's do it next year. And I quote, compared with the fighting in the West, it will be child's play. You know, we talked before about the Soviet war in Finland. He watched that and he said that red army's rubbish. We'll definitely be able to wipe the floor with the Red Army. And this assumption will have a catastrophic effect on the fortunes of Hitler's war and indeed of the Third Reich, won't it?
去那边。但在这次会议上，他对将军们说，进攻苏联，我想我们大概需要80到100个师，明年就动手吧。我引用他的话：“与西线的战斗相比，这简直是小儿科。”你知道，我们之前谈到过苏联在芬兰的战争。他观察了那场战争，并说红军简直是垃圾。我们绝对能把红军打得落花流水。这种假设将对希特勒战争的命运，乃至第三帝国的命运产生灾难性的影响，不是吗？
Anyway, for the time being, the focus is still Britain. The next evening, the 22nd of July, Hitler's about to go off to Bayreuth to hear some Wagner. It's going to hear Gutter Damarung. The downfall of the gods. The downfall of the gods. Exactly. The very last Wagner performance, I think he will ever attend. And just before he leaves Berlin, he hears that Lord Halifax, who's one of the people that he'd hoped would make a deal with him, has actually gone on the BBC and totally rejected any talk of a deal. In fact, even though we think of Halifax as a sort of wimpish, you know, weedy reputation in Britain these days. But if you read the speech, I've read the transcripts of the speech, it's pretty stirring stuff.
总之，目前重点仍然是英国。第二天晚上，即7月22日，希特勒正准备去拜罗伊特听瓦格纳的歌剧。他要去听《诸神的黄昏》。诸神的黄昏。没错。我想这将是他参加的最后一场瓦格纳演出。就在他离开柏林前，他听说哈利法克斯勋爵——他曾寄希望于与之达成协议的人之一——竟然在BBC上彻底拒绝了任何关于达成协议的谈话。事实上，尽管我们现在认为哈利法克斯在英国有一种软弱、无能的声誉，但如果你读过他的演讲，我读过演讲的文字记录，那是非常令人振奋的内容。
Halifax says, we realize that the struggle may cost us everything, but just because the things we're defending are worth any sacrifice, it is a noble privilege to be the defenders of things so precious. You don't sort of associate that kind of quite rousing stuff with Halifax. I imagine he was too tall and languid to engage in such rhetoric. You're tall and languid, and you often engage in such rhetoric, no? I wouldn't have been able to come up with that. Oh, you're too hard on yourself.
哈利法克斯说，我们意识到这场斗争可能会让我们付出一切，但正因为我们所捍卫的东西值得任何牺牲，成为这些珍贵事物的捍卫者是一种崇高的特权。你不会把那种相当激昂的东西与哈利法克斯联系起来。我想他太高大、太懒散了，无法进行这样的修辞。你又高大又懒散，而且你经常进行这样的修辞，不是吗？我可想不出那种话。哦，你对自己太苛刻了。
I can't believe I'm saying that because it's not even true. Hitler's options now are very narrow. So it's looking like they are going to have to attack Britain. Before he goes off to here, there's Wagner, he says to Goebbels, prepare the ground with the people, use the radio, leaves the newspapers. Then he goes off to Wagner and then he goes off to the Berghoff, his mountain lair, where he's going to spend the last weeks of July. And all the time, his commanders are working on this invasion plan. So they assemble very Napoleonic, a fleet of flat-bottomed barges to get across the channel, and they've got embarkation points on the channel coast, just as Napoleon did.
我不敢相信我说了这些，因为这甚至不是真的。希特勒现在的选择非常有限。所以看起来他们不得不进攻英国。在他去听瓦格纳之前，他对戈培尔说，要做好民众的思想工作，利用广播，留下报纸。然后他去听了瓦格纳，接着去了他的山间巢穴贝格霍夫，他将在那里度过7月的最后几周。与此同时，他的指挥官们正在制定这个入侵计划。于是他们组建了一支非常拿破仑式的平底驳船舰队来横渡海峡，他们像拿破仑一样，在海峡沿岸设有登船点。
What about the sea fensibles? Exactly, we should have called out the sea fensibles. Well, you described them as the kind of Dad's Army of the Napoleon Wars, didn't you? Because this is the heyday of Dad's Army, isn't it? The Home Guard are busy dusting down their wooden rifles and things. Retired bank managers in Britain. parading and drilling in preparation for a life or death struggle against Hitler's war machine. Makes you proud to be a British, Tom.
那“海防民兵”呢？没错，我们本该召集“海防民兵”的。嗯，你把他们描述为拿破仑战争时期的“老爸的军队”，对吧？因为这是“老爸的军队”的全盛时期，不是吗？国土防卫军正忙着掸掉他们的木制步枪之类的东西。英国的退休银行经理们在游行和操练，为与希特勒的战争机器进行生死搏斗做准备。这让你为身为英国人感到自豪，汤姆。
Now, meanwhile, the bloke who tried to kidnap Edward VIII, Valtes Schellenberg, the SS guy, he has been told to prepare a handbook for the German troops when they land in Britain. And this is a thing that you can buy now in gift shops. Britain, you've seen this? Yes. He was obsessed by the boy Scouts, wasn't he? He saw them as a sinister paramilitary organization that would need to be. eliminated. And I'm delighted to say Britain's historic public schools. There's a guide to Britain's
现在，与此同时，那个试图绑架爱德华八世的家伙，瓦尔特·谢伦伯格，那个党卫军成员，他被告知要为德军登陆英国后准备一本手册。这是你现在可以在礼品店买到的东西。英国，你见过这个吗？是的。他痴迷于童子军，不是吗？他把他们视为一个险恶的准军事组织，需要被消灭。我很高兴地说，英国历史悠久的公立学校。那里有一份英国顶级寄宿学校的指南，因为它们也被视为资本主义爱国主义的温床。难道没有轰炸哈罗公学的计划吗，那是丘吉尔的母校？丘吉尔的母校。是的，我喜欢这个。你在那个邪恶的计划中察觉到了里宾特洛甫的影子。嗯，还有一份疯狂的名单，上面有2800名将被逮捕的人。以及纳粹战争机器中负责拘留他们的具体部门。所以有丘吉尔、张伯伦等等。但也有罗伯特·贝登堡，又是童子军。我的意思是，他显然必须被除掉。
top boarding schools there, because they're also seen as a nest of capitalist patriotism. Weren't there plans to bomb Harrow, which was Churchill's old school? Churchers old school. Yeah, I love that. You detect the hand of ribbon trope in that malevolent plan. Well, also, there's a mad list of 2,800 people who are going to be arrested. And details of which which bit of the Nazi war machine would be in charge of detaining them. So there's Churchill and Chamberl and so on. But there's also Robert Baden Powell, the Scouts again. I mean, he's got to go, clearly.
H.G.威尔斯，而且非常不是节目的朋友，弗吉尼亚·伍尔夫也将被逮捕和拘留。而且希特勒还在密谋把纳尔逊纪念柱搬到柏林，不是吗？是的。我告诉你谁不在名单上，其实。大卫·劳合·乔治。你认为这是为什么？我想是因为他们真的认为他是那种会成为英国的贝当元帅的人。我不是说他会，但我认为他们觉得他可能会。实际上，尽管他们正在起草所有这些东西。但问题是，你看，我不认为他们真的想过他们会这样做，因为他们有关于纳尔逊纪念柱的疯狂想法，但他们从未真正制定过关于被占领的英国会是什么样子的严肃计划。他们之所以不这样做，以及为什么即使到现在还有这么多关于纳粹统治下的英国会是什么样子的猜测，是因为海军和陆军从未真正认为他们会这样做。
H.G. Wells and very much not a friend of the show, Virginia Woolf was going to be arrested and detained. And also Hitler is plotting to move Nelson's column to Berlin, isn't he? Yes. I'll tell you who's not on the list, actually. David Lloyd George. And why do you think that is? I think because they are genuinely thinking he's the kind of person who would actually be the Marshal Paitain. Britain. I'm not saying he would, but I think they think he might be. Actually, even though they are drawing up all this stuff. But the thing is, see, I don't think they ever really thought they would do it because they have got these mad ideas about Nelson's column, but they never really draw up a serious plan about what an occupied Britain would look like. And the reason they don't do that, and the reason there's so much speculation even now about what a Nazi Britain would have been like, is because the Navy and the
所以7月底，雷德尔海军上将来到希特勒的巢穴，基本上对他说，我们今年秋天可能准备不好。理想情况下，你知道，我想等到1941年。我想雷德尔的意思其实是永远不。是的，永远不。但他还是没跟陆军说话，是吗？不，不，不，他们并没有真正交谈。在纳粹政权中，他们都互相憎恨。我的意思是，可以理解，因为他们都是可怕的人。现在，希特勒有一种强烈的紧迫感。你知道，他认为自己随时会死。他认为他的经济会崩溃，他是对的。他认为长期战争将有利于英国人。同样，他是对的。同样，拿破仑时期的回响，封锁。没错。这些模式的存在是有原因的。你知道，英国舰队还在那里。英国工业还在那里。英国是一块难啃的骨头。即使现在，他也在考虑苏联的选择。你知道，他正在对他的将军们说，你知道吗，实际上，如果我们不进行入侵，我们可以转而进攻俄国。哈尔德有7月31日会议的记录。随着俄国的粉碎，英国最后的希望将破灭。德国将成为欧洲和巴尔干半岛的主宰。决定。因此，俄国的毁灭必须成为这场斗争的一部分。如果我们从1941年5月开始，我们将有五个月的时间来完成这项工作。
army never really think they're going to do it. So at the end of July, Admiral Rader came to Hitler's lair and basically said to him, we're probably not going to be ready this autumn. And ideally, you know, I'd like to wait until 1941. And I think Rader really means never. Yeah, never. But he's still not talking to the to the army, is he? No, no, no, they're not really talking to each other. They all hate each other in the Nazi region. I mean, understandably, because they're all terrible people. Now, Hitler's got this great sense of urgency. You know, he's going to, he thinks he's going to die at any moment. He thinks the wheels are going to come off his economy and he's right. He thinks a long war will favor
然而，希特勒说，我们可以稍后再担心这个问题。让我们给这次英国入侵一个机会。现在就开始空中攻击。如果戈林一直对我讲真话，而空军确实像他说的那样好，那我们就稳操胜券了。我们将赢得制空权。如果我们觉得英国人被压垮了，我们就进行攻击。就在第二天，8月1日，他签署了第17号指令，关于对英海空作战。内容如下：空军应在最短时间内以其指挥下的所有力量压倒英国空军，为最终征服英国创造条件。
the British. Again, he's right. Again, echoes of the Napoleonic period, the blockade. Exactly. These patterns are there for a reason. You know, the British fleet is still there. British industry is still there. Britain is a tough nut to crack. Even now, he's thinking about the Soviet option. You know, he's saying to his generals, do you know what, actually, if we don't do the invasion, we could attack Russia instead. Haldor has the notes of the meeting on the 31st of July. With Russia smashed, England's last hope would be shattered. Germany would then be master of Europe and the Balkans. Decision. Russia's destruction must therefore be made a part of this struggle. If we start in May 1941, we would have five months to finish the job.
多米尼克，随着这一指令，德国空军对英国——不是英格兰，是英国——的攻击开始了，令人难以置信的戏剧性。德国会成功击溃英国皇家空军吗？入侵会继续吗？英国会躺在纳粹铁蹄下吗？真的只有一个办法可以知道，那就是在我们进行商业广告时留下来，听听这一集的下半部分。本集由Aura Frames赞助。历史充满了礼物，但最好的礼物是那些持久的。因为照片已经成为我们现代的传家宝。它们就像正在变成历史的当下的碎片。Aura相框让你每天都能重温这些记忆，或者把它们送给你爱的人。那是我们敬爱的制片人西奥在萨拉热窝指着一个烤肉串。在盒子离开前预装照片，添加一条信息，你可以从任何地方更新它。无限存储，无需订阅，只有回忆。在有限的时间内，访问Aura Frame.co.uk，购买Aura最畅销的Carver Mat相框可减免35英镑，该相框被《独立报》评为顶级相框，并在结账时使用促销代码history。
However, Hitler says, we can worry about that a bit later. Let's just give this. British invasion a chance. Let's start the air attack now. If Gurring has been telling me the truth and the Luftwaffe is as good as he says, then we're laughing. We'll win control of the skies. If we get the impression that the English are crushed, we shall proceed to the attack. And the very next day, the 1st of August, he signs directive number 17 for the conduct of air and sea warfare against England. And it reads as follows, Air Force is to overpower the English Air Force with all the forces at its command in the shortest time possible to establish the conditions for the final subjugation of England.
那是auraframes.co.uk，促销代码history。这个独家的黑色星期五网络星期一优惠是他们一年中最好的。所以现在就订购，以免结束。在结账时提到我们以支持本节目。条款和条件适用。本集由Uber赞助。现在，你知道那种在最需要的时候有人为你出现的感觉吗？我们有时都需要那样，Uber知道这一点。Uber不仅仅是一次乘车或送餐，它是在任何情况下都出现。就像为你的远方朋友，在他们生病时送汤，在他们情绪低落时送花。当它真正重要时，无论是什么，你都会出现。
And Dominic, with that, the Luftwaffe's assault on Britain, not England, Britain begins unbelievable drama. Will Germany succeed in knocking out the RAF? Will the invasion go ahead? will Britain lie prostrate under the jack-boot? There is literally only one way to find out, and that is to stay while we have a commercial break and listen to the second half of this episode. This episode is brought to you by Aura Frames. History is full of gifts, but the best are those that last. Because photographs have become our modern heirloom. They're like fragments of the present already turning into history. Aura frames let you relive these memories every day
有志者事竟成，我们在路上。Uber，在路上。今天就下载应用程序。本集由Hotels.com赞助。让你的下一次旅行为你服务。Hotels.com刚刚推出了一项名为“Save Your Way”的改变游戏规则的功能，听起来很简单。当你作为Hotels.com会员预订旅行时，
or give them to someone you love. That is our beloved producer Theo pointing at a kebab in Sarajevo. Preload the photos before it leaves the box, add a message and you can keep updating it from anywhere. Unlimited storage, no subscription, just memories. For a limited time, visit Aura Frame. dot co.uk and get 35 pounds off ora's best-selling carver mat frame named the top frame by the independent and use the promo code history at the checkout.
你决定如何使用你的积蓄。选择现在获得即时优惠，或者将积蓄作为以后的奖励存起来。由你决定。设想将本周住宿的折扣转换为明年豪华海滩度假的奖励。没有复杂的数学，没有停电日期。只有你，选择如何让你的旅行为你更努力地工作，仅在hotels.com。
That's aura frames a ura.c.co.uk promo code history. This exclusive black Friday Cyber Monday deal is their best of the year. So order now before. it ends. Support the show by mentioning us at checkout. Terms and conditions apply. This episode is brought to you by Uber. Now, do you know that feeling when someone shows up for you when you need it most? We all need that sometimes, and Uber knows it. Uber isn't just a ride or a meal delivered, it's showing up no matter what. Like for your long distance friends, bringing soup when they're sick, sending flowers when they're down. When it really matters, whatever it is, you show up.
“Save Your Way”适用于美国和英国的忠诚度会员，适用于有会员价格的酒店。其他条款适用。详情请见网站。我们岛屿、我们帝国乃至全世界每一个家庭的感激之情，除了那些有罪者的住所外，都送给英国飞行员，他们不畏强敌，在不断的挑战和致命的危险中不知疲倦，正以他们的英勇和奉献扭转世界大战的局势。
Where there's a will, we're on our way. Uber, on our way. Download the app today. This episode is brought to you by Hotels.com. Make your next trip work for you. Hotels.com just rolled out a game-changing feature called Save Your Way. and it's as simple as it sounds. When you book a trip as a Hotels.com member,
在人类冲突的领域中，从来没有这么多人欠这么少人这么多。听众们会惊讶地发现，这又是温斯顿·丘吉尔在1940年8月20日在下议院的讲话。欢迎大家回到《历史的其余部分》。英国拒绝了希特勒最后的和平提议，所以元首命令德国空军开始攻击，如果“人山”赫尔曼·戈林的吹嘘是正当的，这将为“海狮行动”，即入侵大不列颠铺平道路。但多米尼克，正如丘吉尔的话所暗示的那样，戈林的人并没有如愿以偿。纳粹处于劣势。他们不是，我真的希望我鼓励你在节目的其余部分用那种声音。
you decide how to use your savings. Choose to take the instant savings now or to bank the savings as rewards for later. It's your call. Envision converting discounts on this week's day into rewards for a luxurious beach getaway next year. No complicated maths, no blackout dates. Just you, choosing how to make your travels work harder for you, only at hotels.com.
老实说，我觉得那会有点烦人。我想会的。现在，西奥非常希望我向在Spotify和YouTube上观看的人指出，我打开了一盏灯。是的，你看起来像打开了一个宝箱。我告诉你，我看起来就像《夺宝奇兵》结尾处那些看着约柜的顶级纳粹分子之一。
Save Your Way is available to loyalty members in the US and UK on hotels with member prices. Other terms apply. See sight for details. The gratitude of every home in our island, in our empire and indeed throughout the world, except in the abodes of the guilty, goes out to the British airmen, who, undaunted by odds, unwearied in their constant challenge and mortal danger, are turning the tide of world war by their prowess
你确实像。或者唐纳德·特朗普，当你有了那盏灯，沙特人。带着球体。那个球体。是的。让我们进入不列颠战役。所以，德国空军自6月以来一直在突袭英国，但在8月，这变得非常激烈。他们想瞄准英国的机场。他们想引诱出英国的飞机并摧毁它们，在入侵前赢得制空权。对于那些对不列颠战役感兴趣的人，汤姆，有一个播客。我不想这样做，因为它是竞争对手节目。一个姐妹节目。这是一个姐妹节目。这是一个兄弟节目。这是一个邻里节目。这是一个邻居节目。这是一个兄弟般的节目。它叫《我们有让你开口的方法》。它由我的兄弟詹姆斯·霍兰德和他的朋友阿尔·默里共同主持。他们最近在那个节目中做了一个关于不列颠战役的系列。我兄弟写了一本关于不列颠战役的精彩书籍。如果你对各种飞机、战略、基础设施等所有细节感兴趣，那就是要去的地方。
and by their devotion. Never, in the field of human conflict, was so much owed by so many, to so few it will astound listeners to learn that that was Winston Churchill again speaking in the House of Commons on the 20th of August 1940 and welcome back everyone to the rest is history Britain has rejected Hitler's final peace offer and so the Fuhrer has ordered the Luftwaffe to begin the assault that
让我们试着在两分钟内总结他们的系列，以一种可能会让你的兄弟和他的联合主持人感到震惊的方式。所以基本上，多亏了丘吉尔的修辞，我们英国人认为皇家空军是“少数人”，你知道，对抗压倒性的优势。实际上，在人力方面，差异并没有那么大。皇家空军大约有3000名飞行员，德国人可能有4000名。是的，但我们仍然，你知道，德国人更多，这就是我们喜欢的，不是吗？他们更多，好吧，不，听着，是的，当然，当胜算对我们不利时，我们喜欢它。现在，在皇家空军机组人员中，有大量的新西兰人、加拿大人和捷克人，最著名的是波兰人。你知道，很高兴波兰人回到节目中。
if Man Mountain Herman Goerings, boasts are justified, will pave the way for Operation C-Lion, the invasion of Great Britain. But Dominic, as Churchill's word suggests, Goering's men are not having things their own way. The Nazis are on the back foot. They aren'ties, and I really hope I encourage you to do the rest of the show in that voice.
波兰人是最大的特遣队。大约有150人。当然，对他们来说，这是绝对个人的。所以最著名的波兰王牌飞行员之一是一个叫博罗索夫·德罗宾斯基的人。他说，我刚才那样做，所以就像我说的，名字，坦率地说。他说，当你看到飞机上的万字旗或黑十字时，你的心跳会快得多。那是一种绝对复仇的感觉。听过我们关于波兰沦陷那一集的人会明白为什么。
I think it would get a bit annoying. to be honest. I think it would do. Now, Theo is very keen for me to point out to people watching on Spotify and YouTube that I've turned a light on. Yeah, you look like you've opened a chest of treasure. I tell you what, I look like one of those top Nazis looking into the Ark of the Covenant at the end of Raiders of the Lost Ark.
绝对。而且我认为，在英国，我们倾向于认为德国空军有点像《星球大战》中那些敌舰，充满了，你知道，钛战机。穿着疯狂制服的可互换坏蛋。但德国空军飞行员也是人，对吧，多米尼克？哦，那很深刻。那很好。因为这一集的重点是从德国人的角度来看不列颠战役。所以告诉我们关于德国空军和飞行员以及所有这些。所以他们和皇家空军一样，处于十几岁。他们大多数是十几岁或二十出头。因为要战斗，你知道，在那样的高度以那样的速度，你必须年轻，因为你需要非常好、非常好的反应能力。基本上，如果你30岁，你就太老了。
You do. Or Donald Trump, when you have that light, the Saudis. With the orb. The Orb. Yeah. Let's get into the Battle of Britain. So, the Luftwaffe had been raiding Britain since June, but it's in August that this becomes properly intense. They want to target the British airfields. They want to lure out Britain's
你知道，这就像成为一名足球运动员之类的。我想是板球运动员。但汤姆，我认识一个板球运动员，他年纪很大，而且对自己的水平大肆吹嘘。你认识这样的人吗？是的，好吧，我显然会在五分钟内被击落。德国空军比皇家空军更鼓励王牌飞行员的崇拜。我们并不真正认为王牌是二战的事情。对我们来说，这是第一次世界大战的事情。
planes and destroy them and win control of the skies before the invasion. And people who are interested in the Battle of Britain. Tom, there's a podcast. I hate to do this because it's a rival show. A sister show. It's a sister show. It's a brother show. It's a neighborly. It's a neighbor show. It's a fraternal show. And it's called We Have Ways for Making You Talk. And it is co-presented by my brother James Holland and his friend Al Murray. And they have been doing a series on the Battle of Britain just recently on that show. And my brother has written a brilliant book on the Battle of Britain. And if you are interested in all the details of the various planes and the strategy and the infrastructure and everything, that is the place to go.
但在德国空军中，这些人有一个叫阿道夫·加兰德的人，还有一个叫弗农·穆尔德斯的人。他们两人都记录了超过100次胜利，德国媒体对这些空中王牌大肆宣传。嗯，我想赫尔曼·戈林曾是索姆河战场上红男爵手下的王牌。是的，没错。
Let's try to summarize their series in about two minutes in a way that will probably horrify your brother and his co-presenter. So basically, thanks to Churchill's rhetoric, we in Britain think of the RAF as the few, you know, against overwhelming odds. Actually, in human terms, the difference isn't that great. The RAF have about 3,000 pilots, the Germans, maybe 4,000. Yeah, but we're still, you know, the Germans have more, and that's how we like it, isn't it? They're more, all right, and not, listen, yeah, of course, we'd like it when the odds are against us. Now, among the RAF crews, there are loads of New Zealanders and Canadians and Czechs, and most famously, polled. You know, it's great to have the polls back on the show.
他是德国空军的指挥官，所以你可以看出它是从哪里来的。他喜欢王牌。是的，没错。有一本关于不列颠战役的精彩书籍，作者叫斯蒂芬·邦盖，他引用了一位叫汉斯·奥托·莱辛的德国中尉的话，他23岁。你得到了和皇家空军飞行员一样的兴奋、恐惧、虚张声势和狂喜的混合体。所以莱辛在7月17日写信给他的父母，
The polls are the biggest contingent. There's about 150 of them. And, of course, for them, this is absolutely personal. So one of the most famous Polish aces was a guy called Boroswof Drobinski. And he said, I just did that, so like I said, the name, frankly. He said, when you saw the swastika or the black cross on the aircraft, your heart beat much quicker. It was a feeling of absolute vengeance. And people who listened to our episode about the fall of Poland will understand why.
我正在度过我一生中最美好的时光。我不会和国王交换位置。和平时期在这之后会非常无聊。不可避免地，他在第二天就被杀了。你认为在德国飞行员方面，有一种几乎是与皇家空军飞行员进行体育竞争的感觉吗，在某种意义上，
Absolutely. And we, I think, in Britain, tend to think of the Luftwaffe as a bit like those kind of enemy ships in Star Wars full of, you know, Thai fighters. Interchangeable baddies in mad uniforms. But the Luftwaffe pilots are humans as well, right, Dominique? Oh, that's profound. That's nice. Because the point of this episode is to look at the Battle of Britain from the point of view of the Germans. So tell us about the Luftwaffe and the pilots and all of that. So they are in their late teens as the RAFR. They're late teens or early 20s, most of them. Because to be fighting, you know, such altitude at such speed, you have to be young because you need really, really good reflexes. Basically, if you're 30, you're too old.
你知道，这些是同行空军，在英格兰南部的天空中相遇，是，你知道，一个体育竞技场。有一点。我的意思是，我认为有时会有这种关于天空骑士的感觉。但实际上，你知道，当你读飞行员的回忆录时，
You know, it's like being a kind of a footballer or something. I think cricketers. But Tom, I know a cricketer who's ancient and makes a huge hullabaloo about how good he is. Do you know such a person? Yeah, well, I would have been shot out of the sky, obviously, within five minutes. The Luftwaffe much more than the RAF encouraged the cult of aces. We don't really think of aces as being a World War II thing. It's a World War I thing for us.
他们经常说，随着时间的推移，当他们失去越来越多的朋友时，他们开始憎恨，那种它是，你知道，一场快乐、运动的遭遇的感觉。那消失了。而且我认为它消失了，特别是对于德国空军，因为他们正在打一场失败的战斗。而且，他们是在敌方领土上空战斗，不是吗？所以如果他们被击落，那么他们也输了。是的，完全正确。
But in the Luftwaffe, that these guys have a guy called Adolf Galland, and there's a guy called Vernon Mulders. And they both recorded more than 100 victories each, and the German press made a huge deal of these air aces. Well, I suppose Herman Goering had been an A-70 over the battlefield of the Somme with the Red Baron. Yeah, exactly.
所以他们有各种劣势。他们的一些飞机很棒。梅塞施密特109，我们现在要进入飞机了。这对我们来说是非常棘手的领域。他们拥有的另一架飞机，110，它们重得多，机动性也较差。皇家空军有两架出色的飞机，喷火式和飓风式。英国人有雷达，这是一个巨大的优势。这是至关重要的，不是吗？
He's in command of the Luftwaffe, so you can see where it's coming from. He loves an ace. Yeah, exactly. There's a brilliant book on the Battle of Britain by Go called Stephen Bungay, and he quotes a German lieutenant called Hans Otto Lessing, who's 23. And you get the same mixture of excitement and fear and bravado and exhilaration that you do with RAF pilots. So Lessing wrote to his parents on the 17th of July,
是的。它实际上是世界上唯一的防空系统。纳粹情报的状态是如此糟糕，以至于他们甚至没有意识到英国人有这个。所以事情是这样的。纳粹情报，你知道，法国沦陷时的情报非常糟糕。但纳粹在不列颠战役中的情报真的，真的非常糟糕。我认为，这很大程度上是他们意识形态傲慢的结果。而且我猜我们的民族失败主义状态就是这样，英国听众可能会发现这
I'm having the time of my life. I wouldn't swap places with a king. Peace time is going to be very boring after this. And inevitably, he was killed. the very next day. Do you think on the part of the German pilots, there's a feeling that almost of sporting rivalry with the RAF pilots, in a sense,
令人惊讶。但在技术上，英国相对于德国是非常、非常先进的。这就是关键所在，不是吗，有了雷达和一般的防空系统，你知道，你直到被指出才真正想到它。但德国空军从未真正抓到地面的英国飞机。不，因为英国人知道他们要来了。英国人总是知道他们要来了，这对于英国在不列颠战役中的成功一定是绝对至关重要的。我认为另一个非常重要的因素是，德国人一直在对自己撒谎。所以实际上，相当高级的人并没有意识到他们的战术不起作用，因为，你知道，没有人告诉他们真相。威廉·夏伊勒，我引用了很多，在8月的一个点，他在柏林的一家咖啡馆遇到了一名战斗机飞行员，这家伙对夏伊勒说，只需要两周，再过两周我们就结束皇家空军了。两周内，英国人将没有任何飞机剩下。我的意思是，讽刺的是，你不可能错得更离谱。8月下旬，凯塞林元帅，他们的高级指挥官之一，被告知，我们，德国空军，只损失了十分之一的战斗机，但英国人损失了一半。这太疯狂了。这完全
you know, these are peer air forces, meeting on the skies over southern England are, you know, a sporting arena. A little bit. I mean, I think there's sometimes this sort of sense over the knights-errant of the skies. But actually, you know, when you read the memoirs of pilots,
完全错误。事实上，整个8月，德国人损失了大约900架飞机，而英国人损失了不到500架。你知道，德国人正在输，他们在流失飞机，但他们也无法更换它们，这非常重要。所以同样，这是英国工业力量的反映，他们在这方面更精通。你一定读过大卫·埃杰顿的书，《英国的战争机器》。这是一本关于英国工业能力在第二次世界大战中杀伤力有多强的启示性书籍，或者我发现它完全让我大开眼界。是的，因为在我们上一集中，我们有关于小船的内容，你知道，关于英国如何赢得战争的浪漫、感伤、怀旧的愿景。我们已经
they would often say, over time, as they lost more and more friends, they grew to hate and the sense of it being, you know, a jolly, sporty encounter. That fades. And it fades, I think, particularly for the Luftwaffe, because they are fighting a losing battle. And also, they're fighting over enemy territory, aren't they? So if they get shot down, then they've lost as well. Yeah, exactly right.
在这一集中开玩笑说“老爸的军队”，关于普通人的想法，我们不会，你知道，假步枪准备对抗纳粹战争机器。事实是，如果1940年欧洲乃至世界上有一台顶级战争机器，那就是英国的，最科学的，技术最先进的，所有这些。现在，其中一些实际上归功于内维尔·张伯伦。所以张伯伦从1938年起就极大地加速了英国的飞机计划。因此，到1940年下半年不列颠战役时，英国工厂生产的战斗机是德国工厂的两倍。而且他们建造它们的速度如此之快，以至于在9月初，尽管有损失，皇家空军实际上拥有的飞机比8月下旬还要多。
So they have various disadvantages. Some of their planes are brilliant. The Messerschmitt 109s, we're getting into the planes now. This is very dodgy territory for us. The other plane they have, which is at 110, they're much heavier and less maneuverable. The RAF have two fantastic planes in Spitfires and Hurricanes. The British have radar, which is a huge advantage. And this is crucial, isn't it?
你知道，他们正在损失飞机，但他们建造它们的速度也如此之快，以至于德国人根本无法竞争。就在这时，德国人开始改变他们的战术。他们开始对机场进行那种攻击。但后来，你知道，戈林总是改变他的战术，把事情搞砸了。他们决定，好吧，我们将进行大规模的群众突袭，有大规模的护航，那种轰炸机的战斗机护航，我们将瞄准英国的城市。所以然后你有了这些巨大的战斗。所以9月7日在肯特和埃塞克斯上空有一场，涉及超过
Yeah. It's effectively the world's only air defence system. And the state of Nazi intelligence is so poor that they don't even realize that the British have this. So here's the thing. Nazi intelligence, you know, Howard intelligence in the fall of France has been awful. But Nazi intelligence in the Battle of Britain is really, really. terrible. And a lot of this, I think, is a result of their ideological arrogance. And I guess our national state of defeatism being what it is, the British listeners may find this
一千架飞机。然后德国人仍然处于劣势。所以那天他们损失了41架飞机，而皇家空军只损失了23架。最著名的例子是9月15日星期日。那一天现在被称为“不列颠战役日”。希特勒下令对伦敦进行大规模攻击，基本上是孤注一掷，因为很明显德国空军的战役没有奏效。我们将引出皇家空军，也许我们将能够消灭他们。数百架轰炸机带着这个巨大的战斗机护航。皇家空军战斗机
surprising. But technologically, Britain is very, very advanced relative to Germany. And that's the kind of key thing, isn't it, that with the radar and the kind of air defense system generally, you know, you don't really think about it until it's pointed out. But the Luftwaffe never really catch British planes on the ground. No, because the British know they're coming. The British always know that they're coming, and that must be absolutely crucial to Britain's success in the Battle of Britain. I think another really important elements, though, is that the Germans are lying to themselves the whole time. And so actually, quite senior people don't realize that their tactics aren't working because, you know, no one is telling them the truth. William Shira, who have quoted a lot, there's a point in August when he meets a fighter pilot in a Berlin cafe, and this guy says to Shira, it's only going to be two weeks, two more weeks and we'll finish with the RAF. In a fortnight, the British won't have any planes left. I mean, the irony, you could not be more wrong. In late August, field marshal Kessel, who's one of their top commanders, is told, we, the Luftwaffe, have only lost a tenth of our fighters, but the British have lost half of theirs. And this is mad. It's completely.
指挥部争先恐后地面对它。所以你有数百架喷火式和飓风式出发，冲向天空。我的意思是，对于从下面观看的人来说，那一定是一个令人难以置信的奇观。结果是一场彻底的英国胜利。所以德国空军那天损失了大约60架飞机。这使他们的水平。一周的损失达到175架飞机。在那里，德国的工厂根本无法及时更换它们。而且人员损失实际上是相当不可持续的。所以到这一点，他们可能已经损失了，死亡、受伤或被俘大约4000名飞行员，是皇家空军损失的两倍。什么，我们进入这场战役已经六周了。而且很明显，即使对德国人来说，戈林也
completely wrong. In fact, across August, the Germans have lost about 900 planes, and the British have lost fewer than 500 planes. You know, the Germans are losing, they're hemorrharing planes, but also they can't replace them, and this is massively important. And so again, this is a reflection of Britain's industrial power, that they are much more proficient at that. You must have read David Edgerton's book, Britain's War Machine. It's kind of revelatory book about just how good at killing Britain's industrial capacity was in the second world, or I found it completely eye-opening. Yeah, because in our last episode, we had the stuff about the little ships, you know, the romantic, sentimental, nostalgic vision of how Britain won the war. We've already
没有赢，他的吹嘘没有得到证实。希特勒那个周末召集了他的武装部队首长。他对他们说，坦率地说，你知道，海狮行动所需的前提条件还不具备。他的副官，名叫尼古拉斯·冯·贝洛夫，说很明显他已经放弃了入侵英国的想法。那个伟大的未知，那个相当即兴的跨海穿越，吓坏了他。他不确定。而那是一个新的东西。我认为，这是整个故事中，在希特勒不可战胜和确定性的光环中的第一道裂痕。他不知道该怎么办。
joked in this episode about Dad's Army, the idea about ordinary people, we wouldn't, you know, fake rifles preparing to fight the Nazi war machine. The truth is, if there's a top war machine in Europe, if not the world, in 1940, it's the British one, the most scientific, the most technologically advanced, all of this. Now, some of this is actually down to Neville Chamberlain. So Chamberlain from 1938 had massively accelerated Britain's aircraft program. So by the second half of 1940 in the Battle of Britain, British factories are producing twice as many fighters as German factories are. And they're building them so quickly that in early September, despite their losses, the RAF actually have more planes than they did in late August.
三天后，他们无限期推迟了海狮行动。它从未真正被带回来。我的意思是，这对希特勒来说很困难，不是吗？因为不可战胜的光环现在确实依赖于这种征服之后的征服感，速度和无情的进步。而海峡是一个真正的问题。你怎么跨越它？而且我猜还有，事实是，据我所知，从来没有真正
You know, they're losing planes, but they're also building them so fast that the Germans just can't compete. And it's at this point the Germans start to change their tactics. They'd started with these kind of attacks on air fields. But then, you know, Goering is always changing his tactics and making a mess of it. They decide, well, we're going to have huge mass raids with massive escorts, kind of fighter escorts of bombers, and we'll target Britain's cities. So then you have these huge battles. So there's one on the 7th of September over Kent and Essex, involving more than
任何纳粹入侵英国的前景。海狮行动从来没有真正奏效。希特勒本人对此感到紧张。他的各位指挥官对此感到紧张。希特勒为入侵所做的准备非常敷衍。而且我收集到，即使是丘吉尔，在他私下的时刻，也认为这不太可能，但他想加强国家的筋骨。所以他有点炒作入侵恐慌来激起英国的舆论。马克斯·黑斯廷斯关于丘吉尔和第二次世界大战的书，他基本上说丘吉尔故意，甚至愤世嫉俗地维持了入侵的幽灵，因为他担心基本上英国人民最终是相当懒惰和被动的
a thousand planes. And then still the Germans are coming off worse. So that day they lost 41 planes and the RAF lost only 23. The most famous example was on Sunday the 15th of September. And that's the day that is now called Battle of Britain Day. And Hitler ordered a massive attack on London, basically a last throw of the dice because it's clear that the Luftwaffe's campaign is not working. We'll draw the RAF out and maybe we'll be able to annihilate them. Hundreds of bombers with this gigantic fighter escort. An RAF fighter
如果恐惧过去，他们会沉回1939年的迟钝中。所以1974年，第二次世界大战的退伍军人，那种高级，那些剩下的高级军官，以及来自英国和西德军队的现任指挥官，在桑赫斯特进行了这场非常大的战争游戏。他们一致得出结论，你知道，德国入侵将是一场彻底的灾难，基本上只有第一波德国军队会跨越。他们不会走得太远，他们都会被杀或被俘，这对国防军来说将是一场灾难。好吧，我提到了《我们有让你开口的方法》。他们做了一集关于那个的精彩节目。
command scrambled everything to face it. So you've got hundreds of spitfires and hurricanes going off, streaking off into the sky. I mean, for people watching from down below, it must have been an incredible spectacle. And the result is a resounding British victory. So the Luftwaffe lost about 60 planes that day. That took their level. losses for the week to 175 planes. And there, Germany's factories just can't replace them in the time. And the human loss is actually pretty unsustainable. So by this point, they've probably lost, killed, wounded or captured about 4,000 pilots, twice as many as the RAF have lost. What, we're six weeks into this campaign now. And it's clear, even to the Germans, that Goering is
而且我认为，正如我从中记得的那样，在那场战争游戏中，他们不得不以某种方式操纵天气模式以确保一些德国人能够跨越。即使那样，正如你所说，他们有点，你知道，他们无法建立滩头阵地。但所有这些都不是为了淡化规模。希特勒在不列颠战役中的失败，因为它确实，我想，不仅为英国，也为被占领的欧洲提供了希望。相反，你知道，有一种溃疡
not winning, that his boasts have not been vindicated. And Hitler summons that weekend, his armed forces chiefs. And he says to them, quite frankly, you know, the preconditions needed for Operation Sea Lion are not yet there. And his adjutant, who is called Nicholas von Beloff, said it was pretty clear that he'd given up on the thought of invading England. The great unknown, the fairly improvised crossing over the sea, frightened him. He was unsure. And that is something new. That's the first chink, I think. In this whole story, in Hitler's aura of invincible, and of certainty. He doesn't know what to do.
在纳粹最高指挥部，甚至可能在希特勒本人心中存在怀疑。是的，我想是这样。我想是这样。所以一旦不列颠战役结束，它就演变成了闪电战。嗯，有点偶然，不是吗？因为德国空军意外地投下了炸弹，我想，在伊斯灵顿。是的。然后英国通过轰炸柏林来回应。我的意思是，从德国的角度来看，这确实是战争的第一次重大冲击之一。有趣的是，皇家空军的攻击，有100架皇家空军飞机，是对柏林的第一次报复性突袭。
And three days later, they postpone Operation C-line indefinitely. It's never really brought back. I mean, it's difficult for Hitler, isn't it? Because the aura of invincibility does depend now on this sense of conquest after conquest, of speed and remorseless progress. And that the channel is a real problem. How do you cross it? And I guess also that the truth is, as I understand it, that there was never really
他们并没有真正造成太大的破坏。我甚至不记得他们杀死了多少人，如果有的话。然后在那之后又连续进行了三次突袭。所以它绝对被柏林人和纳粹最高指挥部体验为一种巨大的挑衅。对于希特勒来说，这是一个真正的冲击。他几天后发表了一次愤怒的演讲，说如果皇家空军继续这样做，我们将消灭他们的城市。因为这是他最不想看到的事情，对于一个他在战前就知道对被拖入世界大战相当焦虑的公众来说，让他们开始失去信心，因为他们自己的城市被
any prospect of the Nazis invading Britain. Operation Sea Line was never really going to work out. Hitler himself is nervous about it. His various commanders are nervous about it. Hitler's preparations for the invasion are very kind of half-hearted. And I gather that even Churchill, in his private moments, thought that it was unlikely, but he wanted to stiffen the sinews of the nation. So he kind of hypes up the invasion scare to rouse British opinion. Max Hastings's books on Churchill and on the Second World War, he basically says Churchill deliberately, even cynically, sustained the specter of invasion because he was worried that basically the British people were ultimately quite lazy and passive
瞄准了。我认为部分原因是，德国人转向了闪电战的轰炸突袭。所以这是对英国城市长达八个月的夜间突袭。基本上计划是希特勒命令德国空军打破英国的士气，摧毁他们的工厂，摧毁码头，摧毁铁路，供应链，燃料库，等等等等。有两三个非常臭名昭著的时刻。所以11月14日的考文垂，大教堂被摧毁了。我想我们在《历史的其余部分》中之前在各个点提到过这一点。市中心，大约600人死亡。
and that if the fear passed that they would sink back into their torpor of 1939. So in 1974, veterans of the Second World War, sort of senior, those senior officers who were left, and current commanders from both the British and the West German military, played out this really big war game at Sandhurst. And they concluded, you know, unanimously that a German invasion would have been a complete disaster that basically only the first wave of German troops would have got across. they wouldn't have got very far and they would all have been killed or captured and it would have been a catastrophe for the Wehrmacht. Well, I've mentioned we have ways of making you talk. They did an excellent episode on that.
12月底的伦敦，29日。这是著名的场景。你知道，你可以谷歌一下。有史以来拍摄的最著名的英国照片之一。圣保罗大教堂上空的巨大烟云，它从火灾中显得无畏。1941年5月10日，我实际上直到查阅它时才意识到这一点。
And I think that as I remember from it, in that war game, they had to kind of rig the weather patterns to ensure that some Germans could get across. And even then, as you say, they were kind of, you know, they couldn't establish a beachhead. But none of that is to downplay the scale. of Hitler's defeat in the Battle of Britain, because it does, I suppose, offer hope not just to Britain, but to occupied Europe. And conversely, you know, there's a kind of canker
伦敦市有两倍多被摧毁。在那天晚上，就像1666年伦敦大火中被烧毁的一样。所以大约1500人死亡。是的，这是淹没伦敦的三大灾难之一。布狄卡起义，大火，然后是闪电战中那天的伦敦。然而，然而，所有这些都远远不足以让英国人坐到谈判桌前。事实上，德国空军作战主管在闪电战一个月后告诉陆军首长，他说，我需要四倍于我拥有的飞机
of doubt in the Nazi High Command and perhaps even in Hitler himself. Yeah, I think so. I think so. So once the Battle of Britain is over, as it were, it kind of evolves into the blitz. Well, kind of accidentally, don't they? Because the German Air Force accidentally drops bombs on, I think, Islington. Yeah. And then the British reply by bombing Berlin. I mean, from a German perspective, that really is one of the first big shocks of the war. The funny thing is the RAF attack, there was 100 RAF planes, was the first retaliatory raid on Berlin.
才能对英国士气产生任何影响，才能产生任何真正的差异。实际上，你可以争辩说，当它缩减时，德国空军已经杀死了大约43000人，这很多，尽管与战争结束时德国和日本轰炸中死亡的人数相比，我必须说。大多数历史学家同意这是完全且彻底适得其反的。我的意思是，马克斯·黑斯廷斯提出了这一点。这实际上是一个有趣的反事实。
They didn't really cause much damage. I can't even remember how many people they killed, if any. Then there are three more raids in rapid succession after that. So it is definitely experienced by Berliners and by the Nazi high command as a massive. provocation. And for Hitler, this is a real shock. He gives a furious speech a few nights later, says if the RAF keep doing this, we will wipe out their cities. Because it's the last thing he wants is for a public that he knew before the war were quite anxious about being dragged into a world war, for them to start losing heart because their own cities are being
如果希特勒只是让英国独自一人，只是说，你知道，在你的岛上炖吧，谁在乎？我不关心你。人们会厌倦战争的。你知道，他们会厌倦所有的配给和经济匮乏等等。是的，我们不能与欧洲建立桥梁吗？对，没错。但事实是，用丘吉尔的修辞来说，他在他们的心中点燃了一把永远不会熄灭的火，对吧？我的意思是，人们很愤怒。然后因为轰炸英国城市。我的意思是，这不是轰炸战役的普遍教训吗？是的。它们是适得其反的，它们总是只会加强被轰炸人民的士气。
targeted. And it's partly because of that, I think, that the Germans move towards the bombing raids of the Blitz. So these are eight months of nightly raids on British cities. And basically the plan is Hitler orders the Luftwaffe to break Britain's morale, destroy their factories, destroy the docks, destroy the railways, the supply chains, the fuel depots, and so on and so forth. And there are two or three very infamous moments. So Coventry on the 14th of November, the cathedral was destroyed. I think we've mentioned this before in the rest of its history at various points. The city centre, about 600 people killed.
有针对性的。我认为部分原因在于此，德国人转向了“闪电战”式的轰炸。这指的是对英国城市长达八个月的夜间空袭。希特勒的计划基本上是命令德国空军摧毁英国的士气、工厂、码头、铁路、供应链、燃料库等等。期间有两三个非常臭名昭著的时刻。比如11月14日的考文垂，大教堂被毁。我想我们在之前的历史回顾中提到过这一点。市中心大约有600人丧生。
London at the end of December, the 29th. This is the famous scene. You know, you can Google it. One of the most famous photos of Britain ever taken. The great clouds of smoke over St. Paul's Cathedral, which is emerging kind of undaunted from the fires. On the 10th of May, 1941, I actually didn't realize this until I looked it up.
12月底的伦敦，也就是29号那天。这是一个著名的场景。你知道，你可以去谷歌搜索一下。这是英国有史以来最著名的照片之一。圣保罗大教堂上空浓烟滚滚，但它似乎在火海中屹立不倒。直到我查阅资料前，我其实并不知道，在1941年5月10日那天，
Twice as much of the city of London was destroyed. on that night, as had been burned in the Great Fire of London in 1666. So about 1,500 people killed. Yeah, it's one of the three great disasters to overwhelm London. Budikas revolt, the Great Fire and then London that day in the Blitz. And yet, and yet, none of this is remotely enough to bring the British to the table. And in fact, the head of Luftwaffe operations told the army chiefs a month into the Blitz, he said, I would need four times as many planes as I've got.
伦敦城被毁的程度是1666年伦敦大火时的两倍。那一晚大约有1500人丧生。是的，这是淹没伦敦的三大灾难之一：布狄卡起义、伦敦大火，以及闪电战中的那一天。然而，这一切远不足以迫使英国人坐到谈判桌前。事实上，德国空军作战负责人曾在闪电战开始一个月后告诉陆军首脑，他说，我需要四倍于现在的飞机数量，
to have any effect really on British morale, to make any real difference. And actually, you could argue, by the time it's scaled down, the Luftwaffe have killed about 43,000 people, which is a lot, though nothing compared with the numbers of people who die in the bombings of Germany and Japan at the end of the war, I have to say. Most historians agree that this is completely and utterly counterproductive. I mean, Max Hastings makes the point. It's actually an interesting counterfactual.
才能真正对英国的士气产生影响，才能真正起到作用。事实上，你可以认为，到空袭规模缩减时，德国空军已经造成了约43000人死亡，这虽然很多，但不得不说，与战争末期德国和日本轰炸中死亡的人数相比，根本不算什么。大多数历史学家认为，这种做法完全是适得其反的。马克斯·黑斯廷斯就指出了这一点。这其实是一个有趣的假设性问题。
If Hitler had just left Britain alone and just said, You know, stew on your island, who cares? I don't care about you. People would have got kind of bored of the war. You know, they'd have got bored of all the rations and the economic privations and so on. Yes, can't we build bridges with Europe? Right, exactly. But as it is, to use Churchillian rhetoric, he kindles in their hearts of fire that will never be extinguished, right? I mean, people are furious. And then because of the bombing of Britain cities. I mean, is this not the universal lesson of bombing campaigns? Yeah. that they are counterproductive and that they always just stiffen the morale of people who are being bombed.
如果希特勒当时放过英国，只是说，你们就在岛上自生自灭吧，谁在乎呢？我不在乎你们。人们可能会对战争感到厌倦。你知道，他们会厌倦所有的配给和经济匮乏等等。是的，我们难道不能与欧洲建立联系吗？没错，正是如此。但事实是，用丘吉尔的修辞来说，他在他们心中点燃了一把永远不会熄灭的火，对吧？我的意思是，人们非常愤怒。而且正是因为对英国城市的轰炸。我的意思是，这难道不是轰炸行动的普遍教训吗？是的，它们适得其反，而且总是只会增强被轰炸民众的士气。
Either kill loads of people or don't bother, I would say is probably the, I mean, that sounds very callous. I mean, if you're going to kill 40,000 people, you're not going to make a massive difference on Britain's morale. Anyway, so where's all this leave the Germans? So we're now in the autumn of 1940, and some of that hysterical enthusiasm of the summer has faded. It's pretty clear now that British are not going to crack. And actually now, I think for the first time, it dawns on a lot of ordinary, Germans. We are in a replay of the First World War after all, the one thing we wanted to avoid, a long war against an island nation with an empire and a fleet and loads of factories
要么就多杀点人，要么就别费劲了，我想这大概是……我的意思是，这听起来很冷酷。我的意思是，如果你打算杀掉4万人，这对英国的士气不会产生巨大的影响。总之，这一切让德国人处于什么境地呢？现在是1940年的秋天，夏天那种歇斯底里的狂热已经消退了。现在很清楚，英国人是不会崩溃的。事实上，我想这是第一次，许多普通德国人开始意识到：我们终究是在重演第一次世界大战，这正是我们想要避免的事情——与一个拥有帝国、舰队和大量工厂的岛国进行一场持久战。
and a huge economic infrastructure. And Hitler's confidence noticed at this point there's a change in his mood. You know, he wanted to get Britain out of the war, but now he can't really think of a way to do it. And there are one or two other disturbing signs. So that autumn, even before the presidential election, Roosevelt agrees the destroyers for bases deal with Churchill. Basically, the British will get 50 very elderly and frankly useless American destroyers. One of Churchill's admiral said they were the worst destroyers I'd ever seen. And in return, the Americans get leases for bases in the Caribbean and in Canada. And it's around this time that one of Hitler's adjutant says of him, the furor seemed
以及庞大的经济基础设施。希特勒的自信心在这一点上发生了变化，你能感觉到他情绪的转变。你知道，他想让英国退出战争，但现在他真的想不出办法。还有一两个令人不安的迹象。那个秋天，甚至在总统大选之前，罗斯福就与丘吉尔达成了“驱逐舰换基地”的协议。基本上，英国人会得到50艘非常老旧且坦率地说毫无用处的美国驱逐舰。丘吉尔的一位海军上将说，这是他见过的最糟糕的驱逐舰。作为回报，美国人获得了在加勒比海和加拿大的基地租约。就在这个时候，希特勒的一位副官说，元首似乎
visibly depressed at the moment he doesn't know what to do next. Now, there are a couple of options. So Grand Admiral Rader says to him, what about the Mediterranean? You know, it's slightly Napoleonic strategy, actually. Get the Italians on board, get the Spanish on board, maybe the French, take Gibraltar, take the Suez Canal. Take Malta? Yeah, exactly, Malta, North Africa, maybe Turkey. And Hitler's quite interested in this. And then he has a series of desire. astrous meetings. So first of all, with Mussolini. Mussolini is more interested in the Balkans. Yeah, he wants Greece, doesn't he? His greedy eyes are fixed on Greece. Yeah. And then two very low moments in Hitler's life. First of all, when he goes to see Marshall Payton. Marshall Payton says,
当时明显很沮丧，他不知道下一步该做什么。现在，有几个选择。大海军上将雷德尔对他说，地中海怎么样？你知道，这实际上是略带拿破仑式的战略。让意大利人加入，让西班牙人加入，也许还有法国人，夺取直布罗陀，夺取苏伊士运河。夺取马耳他？是的，没错，马耳他，北非，也许还有土耳其。希特勒对这一点很感兴趣。然后他进行了一系列灾难性的会晤。首先是与墨索里尼。墨索里尼对巴尔干半岛更感兴趣。是的，他想要希腊，不是吗？他贪婪的目光盯着希腊。是的。然后是希特勒生命中两个非常低落的时刻。首先，当他去见贝当元帅时，贝当元帅说，
you know, personally, I'd love to join the war and collaborate with you, but then I'd need the National Assembly to approve it. And I really don't want to have to recall the National Assembly. Well, maybe we talk about it another time. Probably pass on that. Yeah, I probably pass on that. And then a fun date with General Franco. This I find very amusing. So this is the dictator of Spain, who Hitler had helped in the Spanish Civil War. They meet at the station at Onday in the border between France and Spain.
你知道，我个人很想加入战争并与你合作，但我需要国民议会的批准。我真的不想召回国民议会。好吧，也许我们下次再谈。大概会放弃吧。是的，我大概会放弃。然后是与佛朗哥将军的一次有趣的约会。我觉得这很有趣。这是西班牙的独裁者，希特勒曾在西班牙内战中帮助过他。他们在法国和西班牙边境的昂代火车站会面。
Hitler has very little to offer Franco, but Franco has turned up with a massive wish list of, like, food supplies and arms supplies and all this. Hitler has never met Franco before, and he finds Franco a very, very objectionable man. As Ian Kershaw says, he considered Franco fat, swarthy with a droning sing-song voice reminiscent of an Islamic prayer caller. And Franco makes a dreadful faux power at this meeting. He says to Hitler, do you think you've won the war? I don't think you've won the war. I think even if you got across the channel, the British will never give up. If you got across the channel, the British will just go to Canada and they'll continue with their fleet from Canada with the backing of the United States.
希特勒几乎没有什么能提供给佛朗哥的，但佛朗哥却带着一份巨大的愿望清单出现了，比如食品供应、武器供应等等。希特勒以前从未见过佛朗哥，他觉得佛朗哥是一个非常、非常令人反感的人。正如伊恩·克肖所说，他认为佛朗哥又胖又黑，说话声音单调，像伊斯兰教的宣礼员。佛朗哥在这次会晤中犯了一个可怕的失礼。他对希特勒说，你认为你赢了这场战争吗？我不认为你赢了这场战争。我认为即使你跨过了海峡，英国人也永远不会放弃。如果你跨过了海峡，英国人只会去加拿大，他们会带着舰队从加拿大继续战斗，并得到美国的支持。
And Hitler is absolutely furious at this. He can't believe that Franco is dissing his war effort. And he actually gets up and goes to leave and has to basically be persuaded to sit back down at the table. Anyway, they continue the meeting. And when they get up to go, finally, Hitler says to his men in German, literally, there is nothing to be done with this bloke.
希特勒对此感到非常愤怒。他无法相信佛朗哥竟然贬低他的战争努力。他甚至起身要离开，最后不得不被劝说坐回桌边。无论如何，他们继续了会议。当他们起身离开时，希特勒最终用德语对他的手下说，字面意思就是：这家伙简直无可救药。
And Franco says to his foreign minister in Spanish, these people are intolerable. They want us to come into the war in exchange for nothing. And then after this, Hitler goes and meets Mussolini. Yeah, Mussolini says, how did it go with Franco? and Hitler says, I hate him, I would rather have three or four teeth taken out than have another meeting with that man. He describes Franco as a Jesuit swine. Isn't Hitler very contemptuous of the fact that Franco has made the Virgin Mary a brigade commander in the Spanish army or something?
佛朗哥用西班牙语对他的外交部长说，这些人真是令人无法忍受。他们想让我们以换取什么都没有的代价加入战争。此后，希特勒去见了墨索里尼。是的，墨索里尼问，和佛朗哥谈得怎么样？希特勒说，我恨他，我宁愿拔掉三四颗牙齿，也不愿再和那个人开会。他形容佛朗哥是“耶稣会猪”。希特勒对佛朗哥让圣母玛利亚担任西班牙军队旅长之类的事情感到非常轻蔑，不是吗？
That's right. Yeah. Well, the thing is about Franco that's quite confusing is Franco pretends to be a fascist. You know, he has the trappings of fascism. But Franco, unlike Hitler, is much more backward-looking You know, he's basically an ultra-Catholic, ultra-reactionary, you know, let's turn back the clock to the 16th century, that kind of thing. And Hitler has no patience for that. He wants to power forward into a new order and a new age. Yeah, because that's the essence of Mussolini and of Nazism is the combination of the ancient and the gleamingly modern. Yeah, it's the ancient and the ancient, I think, is what Frank. Like Salazar actually in Portugal, yes.
没错。是的。关于佛朗哥，令人困惑的一点是，佛朗哥假装自己是法西斯主义者。你知道，他有法西斯主义的表象。但佛朗哥与希特勒不同，他更守旧。你知道，他基本上是一个极端天主教徒、极端反动派，你知道，让我们把时钟拨回16世纪，诸如此类。希特勒对此毫无耐心。他想推动进入一个新的秩序和一个新的时代。是的，因为墨索里尼和纳粹主义的本质是古代与闪耀的现代的结合。是的，是古代，我认为这就是佛朗哥。就像葡萄牙的萨拉查一样，是的。
Hitler heads back to Germany by train, and he's very downcast. And so it's now that he returns to that scenario of invading the Soviet Union. And he says to his generals, look, it's win-win. We'll get all the raw materials that we are currently importing from the Soviet Union. We'll get all the grain from Ukraine. We'll get oil from Romania. Oil from the Caucasus. We'll get that colonial empire in the east, which have always wanted for our living space.
希特勒乘火车回到德国，他非常沮丧。所以现在他回到了入侵苏联的那个方案。他对他的将军们说，看，这是双赢。我们将获得目前从苏联进口的所有原材料。我们将从乌克兰获得所有粮食。我们将从罗马尼亚获得石油。从高加索获得石油。我们将得到那个我们一直想要的东方殖民帝国，作为我们的生存空间。
And above all, this is the only way to send. a message to Britain, as he tells formerly general now field Marshal Fedor von Bach, the gentlemen in England aren't stupid, you know. They will realize there's no point in carrying on the war once Russia has been beaten. And what's also been playing on Hitler's mind in the autumn in 1940 is what's Stalin up to? What if Stalin goes into the Balkans? What if Stalin gets the oil in Romania? Molotov comes to Berlin in November, and it's a very difficult meeting. Hitler and Ribbentrop say to Molotov, yeah, we think you should, you should be looking at India. You should be looking at the Middle East. And Molotov isn't
最重要的是，这是向英国传递信息的唯一途径，正如他告诉前将军、现任陆军元帅费多尔·冯·博克的那样，英国的绅士们并不傻，你知道。一旦俄罗斯被击败，他们就会意识到继续战争毫无意义。1940年秋天，希特勒脑子里还在想，斯大林在搞什么鬼？如果斯大林进入巴尔干半岛怎么办？如果斯大林在罗马尼亚获得石油怎么办？莫洛托夫11月来到柏林，那是一次非常艰难的会晤。希特勒和里宾特洛甫对莫洛托夫说，是的，我们认为你应该关注印度。你应该关注中东。而莫洛托夫对此
interested in that at all. He's talking about the Balkans. And Hitler finds this very disturbing. And he says to his adjutant afterwards, Molotov has let the cat out of the bag. You know, basically the Russians are going to muscle in on our territory. And so it's about a week or so after that that Hitler sends his adjutants east. And he says to them, I want you to go into the forests of East Prussia and to find me a good spot for a secret field headquarters. And this is what becomes the wolf's lair. They do love a sinister name for a lair, don't they? The wolf's lair is brilliant.
一点也不感兴趣。他在谈论巴尔干半岛。希特勒觉得这非常令人不安。他事后对他的副官说，莫洛托夫泄露了天机。你知道，基本上俄罗斯人要挤进我们的领土。所以大约一周后，希特勒派他的副官去东方。他对他们说，我要你们去东普鲁士的森林里，为我找一个秘密野战司令部的好地方。这就是后来成为“狼穴”的地方。他们确实喜欢给巢穴起个阴森的名字，不是吗？“狼穴”太棒了。
I'm just going to, this, a Polish tourist board should be paying me for this. It's now in Poland. I had a very, very happy day there with San Bernard Jr. poking around the ruins of like Hitler's bunker, Gurring's bunker, all this. It's incredible. It's brilliant. There's no health and safety, or they're very pitiful attempt to health and safety. so you can basically explore all these tunnels and stuff.
我只是要说，波兰旅游局应该为此付钱给我。它现在在波兰。我和小圣伯纳德在那里度过了非常、非常快乐的一天，在希特勒的地堡、戈林的地堡等废墟中探寻。这太不可思议了。太棒了。那里没有健康和安全措施，或者说他们对健康和安全措施的尝试非常可怜，所以你基本上可以探索所有这些隧道之类的东西。
Well, I think that's what Hitler would have wanted. He would have been contemptuous of health and safety, wouldn't he? Well, yeah, you're right. Fifth of December, Hitler meets spineless, Browkich and Haldor. And he says to them, the Russians are inferior. Their army has no leadership. I want to get this done. My mind is made up.
嗯，我想这正是希特勒想要的。他会蔑视健康和安全，不是吗？嗯，是的，你说得对。12月5日，希特勒会见了软弱的勃劳希奇和哈尔德。他对他们说，俄罗斯人是劣等的。他们的军队没有领导力。我想完成这件事。我已经下定决心了。
Let's attack Russia and force Britain out of the war before the Americans can get involved. Now, the fascinating thing I think is that his generals, who have been horrified, by all his suggestions up till then about attacking other people are not horrified by this one. Now, partly I think it's because he's been talking about attacking the Soviet Union for seven years
让我们进攻俄罗斯，在英国人介入之前迫使英国退出战争。现在，我认为最迷人的是，他的将军们，在此之前对所有关于攻击其他人的建议都感到震惊，但对这个建议却并不感到震惊。现在，我认为部分原因是他在过去七年里一直在谈论攻击苏联，
going back to 1933 when he first became chances, so they've had a lot of time to get used to the idea. So they've had time to adjust to the plan. Yeah, they knew this was always going to come. They all agree that Stalin's empire is rotten and will fall, that basically the Red Army is useless and they say, well, come on, the people in Belarus and Ukraine and stuff,
追溯到1933年他刚成为总理时，所以他们有足够的时间来适应这个想法。所以他们有时间调整计划。是的，他们知道这迟早会发生。他们都同意斯大林的帝国是腐朽的，将会倒塌，基本上红军是无用的，他们说，好吧，来吧，白俄罗斯和乌克兰等地的人们，
they'll probably welcome us with open. arms. And this is their ideology again. They think the laws of racial science mean we're bound to win. The Slavs are useless. They'll never be a Teuton, you know, an Aryan. They're riddled with Bolshevism. And so this will actually be dead easy. It'll be so much easier than fighting the British. What's not to like? And so it is that on the 18th of December, 1940, Hitler issues one of the most fateful orders in history. Furor Directive 21. The German Wehrmacht must be prepared to crush Soviet Russia in a quick campaign
他们可能会张开双臂欢迎我们。这又是他们的意识形态。他们认为种族科学的规律意味着我们注定会赢。斯拉夫人是无用的。他们永远不会成为条顿人，你知道，雅利安人。他们充满了布尔什维克主义。所以这实际上会非常容易。这比与英国人作战要容易得多。有什么不好的呢？于是，在1940年12月18日，希特勒发布了历史上最致命的命令之一。元首第21号指令。德国国防军必须准备在一次快速战役中粉碎苏俄，
even before the conclusion of the war against England. They'll go into the Soviet Union. They will seize Leningrad. They will seize Ukraine's industrial heartland in the Donbass. And above all, they will power towards the Soviet capital in Moscow. And the name of this operation was originally Operation Otto, but now Hitler personally renames it. In honor of the crusading emperor Frederick I, it will now be called Operation Barbarossa.
甚至在对英战争结束之前。他们将进入苏联。他们将占领列宁格勒。他们将占领乌克兰在顿巴斯的工业中心地带。最重要的是，他们将向苏联首都莫斯科推进。这次行动的名称最初是“奥托行动”，但现在希特勒亲自将其重新命名。为了纪念十字军皇帝腓特烈一世，它现在将被命名为“巴巴罗萨行动”。
And Dominic, is that where you are ending this episode and the entire series on that cliffhanger? It is, on that bombshell, on that cliffhanger. That's the way I work. Oh, my God. Well, ladies and gentlemen, we will be back next year, continuing this story, the epic history of the Third Reich. We have war in the Balkans. We have the invasion of the Soviet Union. But we will also be looking at the home front, the euthanasia program, and of course the beginnings of the Holocaust. So Hitler, obviously, a very bad man. Our next series will also be about a very bad man. And that very bad man is Jack the Ripper as we head into the shadows of late Victorian London, telling the story not just of the murders, but of the broader context, the lives of his victims and the world of late Victorian London. Members of the Rest of History
多米尼克，你是在这里结束这一集和整个系列吗，留下了悬念？是的，就在这个重磅炸弹上，在这个悬念上。这就是我的工作方式。天哪。好吧，女士们先生们，我们明年会回来，继续这个故事，第三帝国的史诗历史。我们将有巴尔干战争，我们将有入侵苏联。但我们也将关注国内战线、安乐死计划，当然还有大屠杀的开始。所以希特勒，显然是一个非常坏的人。我们的下一个系列也将是关于一个非常坏的人。那个非常坏的人就是开膛手杰克，我们将进入维多利亚时代晚期伦敦的阴影中，讲述的不仅是谋杀案的故事，还有更广泛的背景，受害者的生活以及维多利亚时代晚期伦敦的世界。“历史的其余部分”俱乐部
Club will get all five of those episodes on Jack the Ripper on Monday. And if you want to join them, then please sign up at the rest is history.com. And of course, Tom, Christmas is coming. So Restis History Club membership makes a absolutely splendid Christmas gift for the history-loving family members or friends in your life. And actually, do you know what? I think people should treat themselves a little bit more than they do. So why not treat yourself to the Restis History Club membership as a little Christmas treat?
的成员将在周一获得关于开膛手杰克的全部五集内容。如果你想加入他们，请在therestishistory.com注册。当然，汤姆，圣诞节快到了。所以“历史的其余部分”俱乐部会员资格是送给生活中热爱历史的家人或朋友的一份绝佳圣诞礼物。而且，你知道吗？我认为人们应该比现在对自己好一点。所以，为什么不给自己买一份“历史的其余部分”俱乐部会员资格作为一份小小的圣诞礼物呢？
Raise a glass of eggnog to that. And for now, goodbye. Bye-bye. Throughout time, celebration has meant giving. So the Romans at Saturnalia handed out all kinds of gifts. The three magi handed out gold, frankincense and myrrh, and the Victorians absolutely loved, wrapping things up in paper and then tying it up in string.
为此举杯庆祝吧。现在，再见。再见。纵观历史，庆祝意味着给予。所以罗马人在农神节上分发各种礼物。三位智者分发了黄金、乳香和没药，维多利亚时代的人非常喜欢用纸把东西包起来，然后用绳子系好。
Some of those are lovely gestures, but I wonder if they're a little bit too extravagant for the typical Christmas morning. So this year, here's my suggestion to our listeners and our viewers. Why not give something a little bit more enlightened? Why not give the gift of the rest is history club membership? It's the discerning choice for anybody who prefers a Hannibal to a hamper.
其中一些是可爱的姿态，但我怀疑它们对于典型的圣诞早晨来说是否有点太奢侈了。所以今年，这是我对我们的听众和观众的建议。为什么不给一些更有启发性的东西呢？为什么不送一份“历史的其余部分”俱乐部会员资格作为礼物呢？对于任何喜欢汉尼拔胜过喜欢礼品篮的人来说，这是一个有眼光的选择。
It's ad-free listening. You get a weekly bonus episode. You get early access to live shows and you get exclusive deep dive series. Also, on top of that, this year's special gift edition of Restis History Club membership comes with a sensational exclusive t-shirt.
这是无广告收听。你每周会得到一集额外节目。你可以提前获得现场演出门票，还可以获得独家深度系列节目。此外，今年特别礼品版的“历史的其余部分”俱乐部会员资格还附带一件轰动性的独家T恤。
It will make you the envy of all your neighbours and all the cool people in your neighbourhood if such people exist will admire you and want to spend more time with you. So just head to therestishistory.com and click on gifts. That is The Restis History.com and please click on gifts. Throughout time, celebration has meant giving.
它会让你成为所有邻居羡慕的对象，如果你周围有酷人的话，他们会羡慕你并想花更多时间和你在一起。所以只需前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”。那就是TheRestIsHistory.com，请点击“礼物”。纵观历史，庆祝意味着给予。
So the Romans at Saturnalia handed out all kinds of gifts. The three magi handed out gold, frankincense and myrrh, and the Victorians absolutely loved wrapping things up in paper and then tying it up in string. It's on those are lovely gestures, but I wonder if they're a little bit too extravagant for the typical Christmas morning. So this year, here's my suggestion to our listeners and our viewers.
所以罗马人在农神节上分发各种礼物。三位智者分发了黄金、乳香和没药，维多利亚时代的人非常喜欢用纸把东西包起来，然后用绳子系好。这些都是可爱的姿态，但我怀疑它们对于典型的圣诞早晨来说是否有点太奢侈了。所以今年，这是我对我们的听众和观众的建议。
Why not give something a little bit more enlightened? Why not give the gift of the rest is history club membership? It's the discerning choice for anybody who prefers a Hannibal to a hamper. It's ad-free listening. You get a weekly bonus episode. You get early access to live shows. And you get exclusive deep dive series. Also, on top of that,
为什么不给一些更有启发性的东西呢？为什么不送一份“历史的其余部分”俱乐部会员资格作为礼物呢？对于任何喜欢汉尼拔胜过喜欢礼品篮的人来说，这是一个有眼光的选择。这是无广告收听。你每周会得到一集额外节目。你可以提前获得现场演出门票。还可以获得独家深度系列节目。此外，今年
year's special gift edition of Restis History Club membership. It comes with a sensational, exclusive t-shirt. It will make you the envy of all your neighbours and all the cool people in your neighbourhood. If such people exist, will admire you and want to spend more time with you. So just head to therestishistory.com and click on gifts. That is therestishistory.com and please click on gifts. Hello there, it's James Holland and Al Murray, hosts of WW2 Pod, We Have Ways of Making You Talk. Yes, so Al and I have been on the rest of history a few times now, haven't we, Al?
特别礼品版的“历史的其余部分”俱乐部会员资格。它附带一件轰动性的独家T恤。它会让你成为所有邻居羡慕的对象，如果你周围有酷人的话，他们会羡慕你并想花更多时间和你在一起。所以只需前往therestishistory.com并点击“礼物”。那就是therestishistory.com，请点击“礼物”。你好，我是詹姆斯·霍兰德和阿尔·默里，二战播客《我们有让你开口的方法》的主持人。是的，阿尔和我已经去过几次“历史的其余部分”了，不是吗，阿尔？
We've been talking all things World War II with Tom and Dominic, and if you've been enjoying their recent series on the invasion of Norway, the fall of France and the Battle of Britain, then we have good news for you. That's right, Jim. We have our own show all about the fascinating history of the Second World War. It's been going for longer than the Second World War itself, haven't we, James? And longer than the rest is history. Twice a week.
我们和汤姆、多米尼克谈论了所有关于第二次世界大战的事情，如果你一直在享受他们最近关于入侵挪威、法国沦陷和不列颠战役的系列节目，那么我们有好消息要告诉你。没错，吉姆。我们有自己的节目，全是关于第二次世界大战迷人的历史。它持续的时间比第二次世界大战本身还要长，不是吗，詹姆斯？而且比“历史的其余部分”还要长。每周两次。
WW2Pod, we have ways to make you talk, discusses the fascinating people, the incredible innovations and the terrible tragedies of this, I think, the most important period of history of all time.
《二战播客：我们有让你开口的方法》，讨论了这一我认为是有史以来最重要的历史时期中迷人的人物、令人难以置信的创新和可怕的悲剧。
Absolutely. The Battle of Hastings, I've got nothing on this. It's 1940, where it's all at. This past year alone now, we've done series, haven't we, on Dunkirk, the Battle of Britain,
绝对的。黑斯廷斯战役，和这个比起来什么都不是。1940年，这才是重点。仅在过去的一年里，我们就制作了关于敦刻尔克、不列颠战役的系列节目，不是吗？
Hitler's last days in Berlin, the dropping of the atomic bombs. And we've also explored the women of SOE, Auschwitz, Malta. And in a midst of all this, we take our listeners' family stories and give them an airing so that people can tell the story of what happened to their Uncle Albert, where maybe
希特勒在柏林的最后日子，原子弹的投下。我们还探索了SOE的女性、奥斯威辛、马耳他。在这一切之中，我们采纳了听众的家庭故事并进行广播，这样人们就可以讲述发生在他们阿尔伯特叔叔身上的故事，也许
they were involved with the siege of Malta. And we're doing loads of naval chat at the moment on the main show, such as the fight against the U-boat Wolf Packs in the Atlantic War. So now is a really fantastic time to subscribe and get yourself a bit more nautical. So, search, We Have Ways, wherever you get your podcasts, and we look forward to you joining us. Prepare to Board. We have ways of making you talk with me, Al Murray, and James.
他们参与了马耳他围城战。我们目前在主节目中有很多关于海军的聊天，比如在大西洋战争中对抗U型潜艇狼群。所以现在是订阅并让自己多了解一点航海知识的绝佳时机。所以，在任何你获取播客的地方搜索“We Have Ways”，我们期待你的加入。准备登船。《我们有让你开口的方法》，我是阿尔·默里和詹姆斯·霍兰德。
Holland. Thank you. Hello there. I'm William Drimple. I am one of the hosts of Empire, the global history podcast from Gollhanger. You may remember my appearances on The Rest is History when we talked about Afghanistan and the East India Company. As the ashes returned down under, Anita and I have launched a brand new Empire series on the history politics and extraordinary cultural power of cricket. In the first episode, we dig into the origin of the ashes, England versus Australia, a rivalry born in the age of empires, and still shaping identity on both sides of the world. Then we travelled to India where cricket began with an impromptu beach match
谢谢。你好。我是威廉·达林普。我是来自Gollhanger的全球历史播客《帝国》的主持人之一。你可能还记得我出现在《历史的其余部分》中，当时我们谈论了阿富汗和东印度公司。随着灰烬杯回到澳大利亚，安妮塔和我推出了一个全新的《帝国》系列，关于板球的历史、政治和非凡的文化力量。在第一集中，我们深入探讨了灰烬杯的起源，英格兰对阵澳大利亚，这是一个诞生于帝国时代的竞争，至今仍在塑造着世界两端的身份认同。然后我们前往印度，板球在那里以一场即兴的海滩比赛开始，
and evolved into a sport that mirrored and sometimes magnified the country's communal divides. We also talk about the great Tiger Borti who revolutionised Indian cricket in the 1960s. And for members of the Empire Club, we go still further from the Great West Indies. Indian players who stood up to racism, to the South African cricketers who challenged apartheid at real personal risk. If you want the full sweep of how cricket changed empires and how empires change cricket, just search for empire wherever you get your podcast. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
并演变成一项反映并有时放大了该国社区分歧的运动。我们还谈到了在20世纪60年代彻底改变印度板球运动的伟大的老虎·帕托迪。对于“帝国俱乐部”的成员，我们走得更远，从伟大的西印度群岛球员，他们勇敢地面对种族主义，到挑战种族隔离制度并冒着真正个人风险的南非板球运动员。如果你想全面了解板球如何改变了帝国，以及帝国如何改变了板球，只需在任何你获取播客的地方搜索“帝国”。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子即可发表评论。